PLEASE. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE-
WELCOME TO THIS YEAR'S FINAL
HEARING FOR BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE WE ARE I THINK FOR
THE FIRST TIME THIS YEAR
COMMUNITIES START WITH THE ROLL
CALL. WITH ATTENDANCE. WELL HERE
SENATE FRIEDMAN YOUR FALLEN
PATTERSON RIVAS. PAUL WE'LL
BEGIN WITH THEY ARE ALL TOO
FAMILIAR PREAMBLE THAT- TODAY
WE'RE HAVING AN IN PERSON
HEARING IN CAPITOL ROOM FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN WE WILL BE TAKING
ACTION ON SOME JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSALS AS WELL SPRING FINANCE
LETTERS MOST IMPORTANTLY WE'LL
BE HEARING A HIGH LEVEL
PRESENTATION OF THE GOVERNORS
MAY REVISION. GIVEN THE STATE'S
HISTORIC SURPLUS THERE'S A LOT
TO DIGEST AND- UNFORTUNATELY A
VERY SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME BUT
WE'VE- GROWN ACCUSTOMED TO THAT
. TODAY WILL PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS TO SPEAK
ON THEIR BUDGET PRIORITIES WITH
REGARD TO CLIMATE AND
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES. AND THEN
WE WILL TRANSITION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PRESENTATION
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
ANALYSIS. FOLLOWED BY MEMBER
QUESTIONS. OUR MOST IMPORTANT
TASK AT HAND TODAY IS TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC TO VOICE THEIR
POSITIONS ON THE MAY REVISE. TO
FURTHER ENGAGE IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS THAT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING THOSE RUSSIANS WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN PERSON MAY DO SO
AFTER THOSE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM HAVE SPOKEN WILL ALLOW
PHONE TESTIMONY. THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE SHOULD BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING THIS HEARING
ONLINE BUT THAT PHONE NUMBER IS
PUBLIC TOLL FREE. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE
THAT YOU'LL NEED IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE NINE. AND
A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU.
THOSE TESTIFYING WILL HAVE UP TO
ONE MINUTE TO SPEAK PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WILL BE UP TO ONE
MINUTE. WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC
TO PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY
WHICH CAN BE EMAILED TO THE
FOLLOWING EMAIL ADDRESS BUDGET
SUB THREE NUMERAL THREE. AT A.
S. M. DOT CA DOT GOV. BEFORE WE
BEGIN I WANT TO THANK OUR PHONE
OPERATORS THE ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS
AND BUDGET STAFF ESPECIALLY
MARCO RODRIGUEZ FOR THEIR
COUNTLESS HOURS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE HEARINGS RUNAS
SMOOTHLY AS POSSIBLE WHICH IS
BEEN VERY CHALLENGING. AS A WITH
GOD THROUGH THE PANDEMIC A
NUMBER OF TECHNOLOGY CHANGES AND
A RECORD SURPLUS. I WANT TO A
PARTICULARLY THANK. GENEVIEVE
MORELOS AND SHY FORBES CHRISTIAN
GRIFFITH WHO UGH UGH A STAFF
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE CHRISTIAN AS-
ALMOST ALWAYS BEHIND THE SCENES-
ABOUT THE- AND- WE HAVE.
ADJACENT HERE WITH US TODAY AS
WELL ARE- OF FINANCE DIRECTOR
ASSEMBLY FINANCE DIRECTOR AND
EACH OF THESE INDIVIDUALS WORKS
EXTREMELY HARD AND WILL BE
WORKING EXTREMELY HARD AS WE
BRING THE- BUDGET HOME IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS. IN EXCUSE ME.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO OPEN THE
FLOOR TO MEMBERS WHO HAD- A LIKE
TO SPEAK TO ANY BUDGET
PRIORITIES RELATED TO OUR
COMMITTEE'S JURISDICTION I'VE
ASKED EACH OF THEM TO HOLD THEIR
COMMENTS TO APPROXIMATELY. THREE
MINUTES. WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO.
IF WE CAN TAKE A OF THAT VOTE
FIRST LET ME FIND IT. BAKER I
THINK. YEAH I'VE GOT IT OKAY SO
. PLEASE KEEP AN EYE ON ME AS WE
GO THROUGH THIS WOULDN'T BE THE
FIRST TIME THAT I MISSED ONE OR
TWO OF THESE- WE HAVE TWO VOTES
TO TAKE. THE FIRST I'D ASK FOR A
MOTION. ON THE FOLLOWING. ITEMS
ITEMS ONE TWO FOUR EIGHT THROUGH. 1-416-182-1320 SEVEN. TWENTY
NINE THROUGH THIRTY THREE.
THIRTY SIX OR THIRTY NINE FORTY
TWO THROUGH FORTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE THROUGH. 526-063-6360 FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT THROUGH EIGHTY ONE
EIGHTY THREE THROUGH EIGHTY
SEVEN. EIGHTY NINE THROUGH
NINETY TWO. NINETY FOUR AND HALF
OF ITEM NINETY THREE RELATED TO
SB SIX ELEVEN AND SB THREE SIXTY
SIX DO I HEAR A MOTION. THANK
YOU ROLL CALL PLEASE WELL HI
SENATE FRIEDMAN MULLIN.
PATTERSON RIVAS BONTA. THANK YOU
WILL HOLD THE- O THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ADULTS BUT AS OF NOW THE
VOTE IS FIVE THE MEASURE PASSES
. THANK YOU. THE NEXT MOTION I
ASK FOR IS ON ITEM THREE FIVE
THROUGH. SEVEN FIFTEEN SEVENTEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY FOUR THIRTY FIVE FORTY
FORTY ONE FORTY EIGHT FIFTY
THREE THROUGH. FIFTY NINE SIXTY
ONE SIXTY TWO SIXTY SIX TO SIXTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY FIVE AND A HALF OF ITEM
THREE RELATED TO SB TWO CHEN AND
AB SEVEN NINETY SIX. DURING OUR
MOTION. HELLO WELL I SENATE.
FRIEDMAN MULLIN PATTERSON RIVAS
FONG THAT MEASURE THREE TWO
EXAMPLE WILL HOLD THAT TO OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. AND NOW WE
WILL ALLOW MEMBERS SAID- WHO
WISH TO SPEAK ON THEIR BUDGET
PRIORITIES. MS FRIEDMAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN THANKS
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK AND YOUR
COMMITTEES WORK ON ALL OF THESE
ISSUES OTHER MAY REVISE REFLECTS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL OF
NINE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE THIS
INCLUDES FOUR POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN PROP ONE EIGHTY BOND
FUNDS FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL TWO
BILLION GENERAL FUND FORD
STATEWIDE TRANSIT AND RAIL
PROJECTS AND ONE POINT TWO FIVE
BILLION FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS ARE I
HAPPEN TO BELIEVE THAT INVESTING
IN TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
IS A DOWN PAYMENT ON THE FUTURE
OF THE STATE. I HITS ALL OF OUR
GOALS CLIMATE EQUITY- EVERYDAY
QUALITY OF LIFE ISSUES HOUSING-
CREATING JOBS SO I AM VERY HAPPY
TO SEE THIS KIND OF INVESTMENT.
IN OUR FUTURE AND I'M ESPECIALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSED IN THE
MAY REVISE FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION AND I LOOK FOR TO
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION SO THAT WE CAN
FIND A PATH FORWARD IT SHOULD
PACKAGE I WANT TO SAY A FEW
THINGS I'D LIKE TO SEE IN THAT
PACKAGE AS WE GO FORWARD AND
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS FOR US TO
CONSIDER AND THE ADMINISTRATION
TO CONSIDER FIRST OF ALL I THINK
THAT WE DO NEED AND SHOULD
EXPECT INCREASED OVERSIGHT OF
pTHE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT. AND
GUARD RAILS PUT IN PLACE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE STATE FUNDS CAN
COULD SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE A
PORTION OF THAT PROJECT THAT IS
USEFUL DAY ONE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA- AND I WOULD ALSO.
LIKE TO SEE MORE FUNDING MADE
AVAILABLE FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION. GIVEN OUR
CLIMATE GOALS ARE MOBILITY GOALS
AND THE FACT THAT. WE ARE SEEING
A CONTINUING INCREASE IN
CYCLISTS AND PEDESTRIAN
FATALITIES ACROSS THE STATE TO
THE POINT WHERE IT IS A SERIOUS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. SO I. CAN
WE. APPLAUSE MY TIME IF THAT'S
OKAY INTO A RESOLVER RINGING
PHONE ISSUE. OKAY THANK OKAY
NOPE I DON'T KNOW WHAT. THAT WAS
A VERY GUILTY KIND OF A- THE
RESPONSE- SO- OFF THE HOOK YEAH
SO YOU'RE OFF THE HOOK SO- SO
YEAH I WOULD LIKE TO SEE. A MORE
FUNDING FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION I WOULD SAY THAT
ARE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION-
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
OVERSUBSCRIBED FOR THE LAST FEW
YEARS WE'VE GOT CITIES ACROSS
THE STATE AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE WHO HAVE PROJECTS THAT ARE
SHOVEL READY READY TO GO THAT
WILL SAVE LIVES FOR THEIR
CONSTITUENTS- BUT THEY ONLY
HAVEN'T BEFORE BECAUSE- OF A
LACK OF FUNDING. YEAH IT'S FUNNY. OKAY NO PROBLEM SORRY WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO DEAL WITH SOME
TECH TECHNOLOGICAL ISSUES HERE-
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS A SO OF I DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSED FOR INCENTIVE
GRANTS TO TRANSIT AND RAIL
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE FREE
TRANSPORTATION MONTHS AND IT
SOUNDS VERY LAUDABLE AND OF
COURSE THERE ARE YOUR SOME
SPECIFIC POPULATIONS THAT CAN
BENEFIT FROM FREE TRANSIT MANY
OF THEM ALREADY RECEIVE THAT
THROUGH VARIOUS PROGRAMS ACROSS
THE STATE HOWEVER. WHEN YOU DO
WE DO FOCUS GROUPS WITH TRANSIT
RIDERS AND WE ASK THEM WHAT THEY
WANT TO SEE FREE TRANSIT IS
RARELY EVEN ON THE LIST WHAT
TRANSIT RIDERS CONSTANTLY SAY IN
THIS IS CONSISTENT ACROSS THE
STATE THAT THE FARES ARE NOT A
BARRIER TO PEOPLE TAKING
TRANSIT. AND IT'S NOT A PRIORITY
FOR THOSE RIDERS BUT WHAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS MORE-
COMPREHENSIVE SERVICE THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE SERVICE THAT IS AT
MORE CONVENIENT TIMES AN
EXPANDED TIMES THEY DON'T HAVE
TO WAIT THEY WANT TO SEE CLEANER
PUBLIC TRANSIT AND THEY
CERTAINLY WANT TO SEE SAY FOR
PUBLIC TRANSIT SO I WOULD
STRONGLY SAID MINISTRATION
CONSIDER ALL TRANSIT AGENCIES TO
INSTEAD USE THESE FUNDS TO
INCREASE THE SERVICE THAT THEY
OFFER TO IMPROVE THE SERVICE
THAT THEY OFFER- AND MAYBE
TARGET FREE TRANSIT JUST CERTAIN
POPULATIONS WHO SAY THAT THEY
NEED IT. BUT TO ALLOW THEM THE
FLEXIBILITY TO USE THAT MONEY TO
IMPROVE TRANSIT SO THAT MORE
PEOPLE WANT TO USE IT- THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT USING GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUNDS FOR PROJECTS
THAT WOULD QUALIFY AS CAPITAL
OUTLAY UNDER THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT INCLUDING
HIGH SPEED RAIL TRANSIT PROJECTS
AND INCENTIVES FOR HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES I WOULD LIKE TO EXPLORE
SWAPPING GIGI R. F. FOR GENERAL
FUND FOR TRANSPORTATION CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS AND USED EACH
YEAR AFTER CLIMATE RELATED
ACTIVITIES FOR THE NON
EXCLUDABLE PROJECTS. THIS WOULD
REDUCE OVERALL GENERAL FUND
SPENDING SUBJECT TO THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT AND HELP
MEET NEARLY TWO BILLION DOLLAR
ABOUT ADDRESS REQUIREMENTS. IN
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO AND
TWENTY THREE. I'M SHIFTING GEARS
TO ANIMALS FOR A MOMENT-
HIGHWAYS OR MAJOR BECAUSE OF
WILDLIFE DEATH IN CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE ALSO A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE DECLINE OF
WILDLIFE POPULATIONS THAT BECOME
ISOLATED BY HABITAT
FRAGMENTATION I LOSE
CONNECTIVITY THROUGHOUT THEIR
RANGE AND THIS OBSTACLES TO
WILDLIFE MOVEMENT IS ALSO A
MAJOR THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
ON AVERAGE FIVE PEOPLE ARE
KILLED AND OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PEOPLE ARE INJURED IN
CALIFORNIA IN REPORTED VIEW
WILDLIFE VEHICLE COLLISIONS
EVERY YEAR I APPRECIATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING THAT WE
PROVIDE FORTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
FOR THE FISH PASSAGE WILDLIFE
QUARTERS PROGRAM WHEN THE NEED
FOR THIS PROGRAM IS TOO GREAT
AND I WOULD PROPOSAL WE ALLOCATE
AN ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT
PROGRAM. FOR A TOTAL OF A
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS THIS YEAR AND MISTER
BLOOM I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN A
HUGE CHAMPION OF THIS ISSUE OVER
THE YEARS SO I'VE I'M JUST HERE
TO SAY LET'S GIVE IT MORE MONEY
BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS. I WAS I KNOW I'M SPEEDING UP
OKAY- IT'S GREAT TO SEE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND I'M ALMOST
DONE PUT FORTH THE AMBITIOUS
SPENDING TO TACKLE THE CLIMATE
CRISIS AND SUPPORT CLEAN ENERGY.
IT'S MY HOPE THAT WE'RE NOT ONLY
MAKING CONSENT OF MONEY
AVAILABLE BUT THAT WERE ALSO
LEVERAGING THE AVAILABILITY OF
INCENTIVES TO CREATE ROBUST
POLICY FRAMEWORKS SO THAT CLEAN
ENERGY SOLUTION PROVIDERS CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO SCALE AND THRIVE
WHEN INSTEAD OF MONEY MIGHT NOT
BE AVAILABLE IN FUTURE BUDGET
YEARS. AND WHILE I SUPPORT
INCENTIVES FOR CLEAN DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES WE ALSO NEED TO
TAKE A HARD LOOK AT HOW TO MAKE
SURE THESE RESOURCES CAN PROVIDE
RELIABILITY AND VALUE AND
SATISFY RELIABILITY CONCERNS
THAT WE HEAR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR
SYSTEMS OPERATORS. SOLAR AND
STORAGE CREATE THE ABILITY FOR
CUSTOMERS TO REDUCE THEIR CARBON
FOOTPRINTS. AND TO MEET THEIR
CLEAN ENERGY AND RECITE THE
RESILIENCY LEADS. ABOUT
INCENTIVES ALONE WON'T SCALE
THIS DISTRICT WON'T SCALE
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES AND
WE HAVE TO LEVERAGE THESE
RESOURCES PROVIDE VALUE TO THE
WHOLE GRID. TO ENSURE THAT
CUSTOMERS WHO CAN'T. PARTICIPATE
DIRECTLY IN SOLAR CAN ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN ALSO BENEFIT AND
IN WHAT THEY PROVIDE. AND
LASTLY. I SUPPORT TO ALLOCATING
TWO HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
THIS YEAR'S STATE BUDGET ABOVE
ARE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
BUDGET. TO THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES TO FILL THE MISSION TO
CREATE A MAJOR REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION ROUTE. TO CONNECT
PEOPLE ALONG THE L. A. RIVER.
AND PRETTY AND PROVIDE SAFER
CLEANER AND MORE SUSTAINABLE
OPTIONS FOR REGION WIDE
MOBILITY. THE L. A. RIVER ONES
FIFTY ONE MILES TO THE HEART OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. WITH THE
FIRST THIRTY TWO MILES OF ITS
COURSE WITHIN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. THE ONLY REMAINING
SECTION. OF THE L. A. RIVER.
THAT IS YET TO BE FULLY FUNDED
IS IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
WHICH IS HOME TO ALMOST TWO
MILLION PEOPLE. WERE
APPROXIMATELY THIRTEEN MILES OF
PATH REMAIN INCOMPLETE. THIS
MAJOR SEGMENT WHEN COMPLETED
WILL CREATE A ROUTE THAT WILL
ALLOW FOR CAR FREE AND SAFE.
MOBILITY FROM CANOGA PARK ALL
THE WAY TO LONG BEACH. AND
DOZENS OF DESTINATIONS IN
BETWEEN. AND FURTHERMORE THE
RIVERS PROXIMITY TO CHEAP TO
KEEP TRANSIT STATIONS AND MAJOR
BUS ROUTES WILL ALLOW USERS OF
THIS. L. A. RIVER WAY TO
SIGNIFICANTLY ENHANCE THE
MOBILITY THROUGH THE L. A. METRO
SYSTEM AND THEN WE HAVE
TRIBUTARIES THAT WILL ALSO OFFER
FUTURE SPINE INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY. THE MANY
NEIGHBORHOODS WE CAN GREEN UP
THESE AREAS MANY OF WHICH ARE
PART POOR. AND SO I THINK THAT
THAT IS A VERY PRUDENT
INVESTMENT TO DOUBLE DOWN ON THE
HUGE INVESTMENTS OF THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES. HAS ALREADY MADE
WITHOUT IT YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
MISTER CHAIR. YOU'RE WELCOME.
MISTER BENNETT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS IS THE END OF- MY
SECOND CYCLE HERE WITH THE OF
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE THREE AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY SINCERELY- THIS
COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY YOU MISTER
BLUMEN AND THE STAFF AS IS
GENERALLY EARNED MY RESPECT- IN
TERMS OF HANDLING A LOT OF
COMPLICATED ISSUES AND THE WAY
WE RUN THE MEETINGS AND THEN THE
PRESENTATIONS THAT WE'VE MADE I
FELT AS A NEW MEMBER JOINING US
JOINING A VERY. SMOOTH RUNNING
OPERATION SO THANK YOU
SINCERELY- I ONLY WANT TO
MENTION TWO THINGS ONE THE
IMPENDING- PEAK HOUR GRID
SHORTAGE THAT- THE GOVERNOR HAS
RECENTLY MADE US AWARE OF- I.
BELIEVE THAT- YOU KNOW ONE
APPROACH TO THAT IS STIFF
CONTINUE FOSSIL FUEL- BUT I
THINK ANOTHER APPROACH THAT- I
HOPE WE CAN MAXIMIZE IS THAT THE
MORE STORAGE WE HAVE THE MORE WE
CAN STORE THE ENERGY THAT- WE
HAVE AN ACCESS DURING NON PEAK
HOURS- THE BETTER OFF WE'LL BE
DURING THOSE SHORTAGE PERIODS IN
THE LAST- FOSSIL FUEL
CONSIDERABLE KEEP ONLINE. SO
GIVE AN EXAMPLE I HOPE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION. WELL WILL DO
SAYING THAT PRIORITIZE PROJECTS
THAT HAVE STORAGE FOR EXAMPLE-
EVEY CHARGING STATIONS IF WE
COULD PRIORITIZE EVEY CHARGING
STATIONS THAT ALSO INCLUDES
STORAGE IN THEIR PLANNING SO
THAT WE COULD COUNT ON THEM TO
USE THEIR STORIES AT EIGHT
O'CLOCK IN THE EVENING DURING
PEAK HOURS AND THEY COULD CHARGE
UP THE THERE- THEIR BATTERIES
DURING NON PEAK HOURS- THE OTHER
THING THAT I WOULD JUST. HOPE
THAT WE CAN PRIORITIZE IS- JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP
PLANNING AHEAD DURING THE
PRESENTATION OF THE GOVERNOR
SAID PROPOSAL WE WERE TOLD IT
TAKES SIX YEARS ON AVERAGE FOR
THESE PROJECTS TO COME ONLINE-
AND IF IT TAKES SIX YEARS WE
SHOULD MAKE SURE WE'RE PLANNING
SIX YEARS OUT- AND THAT MEANS
EVERY AGENCY THAT IS INVOLVED
NEEDS TO HAVE US AS A STRONG
SENSE OF ACCOUNTABILITY TO THAT
LONG RANGE PLANNING. AND WITH
THOSE TWO THINGS L. RELINQUISH
THE REST OF MY TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. MR FONG. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- MY REVIEW OF THE
MAY REVISION- I THINK HIGHLIGHTS
THE FACT THAT I THINK THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT MISSED OPPORTUNITIES
ON SEVERAL VITAL ISSUES- WHICH
RIGHT NOW IN OUR STATE WE'RE AT
CRISIS LEVELS CALIFORNIANS ARE
FACING THE THIRD YEAR OF A
DEVASTATING DROUGHT. THE BONE
DRY A DROUGHT CONDITIONS WILL
pMAKE OUR ENERGY CRISIS FAR WORSE
ROLLING BLACKOUTS ARE A LIKELY
POSSIBILITY GAS PRICES ARE OVER
SIX DOLLARS PER GALLON- IT WILL
INCREASE UNFORTUNATELY ON JULY
FIRST BECAUSE OF THE INACTION OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND WATER
RESERVES ARE DRAINING. THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION FAILS TO
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE CRITICAL
NEEDS EVERYBODY WILL WHILE BY
PREVENTION TO WATER STORAGE TO
GAS PRICES- AND THE IMMEDIATE
RELIEF THAT'S NECESSARY THERE
WHILE BY PREVENTION FUNDING
ACTUALLY DECREASED FROM LAST
YEAR- WHERE THE BUDGET HAVE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IT
NOW GOES TO SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THERE'S NO FUNDING FOR
ABOVE GROUND WATER STORAGE THIS
YEAR. AND THE STATE'S SHARE OF
THE DIESEL SALES TAX IS BEING
SUSPENDED BUT NO IMMEDIATE GAS
TAX RELIEF FOR THE EVERYDAY
CALIFORNIA AS CONDITIONS GET
GRAMMAR CALIFORNIANS CANNOT
AFFORD TO WAIT ANOTHER THREE
YEARS FOR WATERS FOR NEW WATER
STORAGE AND THEY CERTAINLY
CANNOT WAIT OUT ANOTHER WILDFIRE
SEASON BEFORE THE STATE COMMITS
TO SERIOUS WILDFIRE PREVENTION I
RECENTLY WAS IN THE SEQUOIA
NATIONAL FOREST 19% OF OUR
ICONIC. GIANT SEQUOIAS HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED. IF WE DON'T. ACTIVELY
STREAMLINED- PREVENTION. ARE WE
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE EXISTS AS A
STATE FOR ALLOWING ALL OUR GIANT
SEQUOIAS TO BE DESTROYED AND
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE EVEN MORE
IN THE IMMEDIATE FUTURE IS THE
GAS TAX INCREASE GOING INTO
EFFECT ON JULY FIRST
CALIFORNIANS ARE HURTING AS OUR
FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS GROW. THE
NEED FOR SUSPENDING THE GAS TAX
IS IMMEDIATE AND WITH MORE AND
MORE STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
TAKING ACTION CALIFORNIA IT
SHOULD DO THE SAME I WILL ALSO
SAY THAT WE NEED TO ALLOW FOR
MORE ENERGY PRODUCTION
ESPECIALLY IN THE AREAS OF OIL
AND NATURAL GAS CALIFORNIA. IS A
ENERGY ISLAND. IF OTHER STATES
INCREASE THEIR OIL NATURAL GAS
PRODUCTION TO SECURE THEIR
ENERGY SUPPLY. IT DOES NOT MEAN
THAT THAT PRODUCTION WILL COME
TO CALIFORNIA WE DON'T HAVE THE
PIPELINE INFRASTRUCTURE
TRANSPORTATION COSTS MAKE IT
ECONOMICALLY- YEAH OUT OF THAT
DOESN'T ALLOW IT TO ECONOMICALLY
PENCIL OUT. SO WE HAVE TO DO. A
PRODUCTION HERE. IN CALIFORNIA
THIS HAS TO BE A PRIORITY. AND
NOT- AND WHEN WE AS A STATE
CANNOT BE PUTTING UP ADDITIONAL
ROADBLOCKS. BECAUSE IF WE DON'T
ACT. THEN THE FOREIGN RELIANCE.
ON ENERGY SUPPLY IN OIL NATURAL
GAS AS A STATE IN CALIFORNIA
WILL ONLY GO UP. AND I HEAR THIS
FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
THAT THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FOREIGN RELIANCE ON ENERGY BUT
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE POLICIES-
AND THE LACK OF INVESTMENT IN
ENERGY PRODUCTION IN. IN IN THE
OIL AND NATURAL GAS SPACE THAT
IS ONLY MAKE THAT WORSE. SO WE
HAVE A LESS THAN A MONTH TO PUT
TOGETHER A BUDGET THAT PROVIDES
REAL SOLUTIONS. HONEST RESPONSES
TO THE PROBLEMS FACING
CALIFORNIA'S I HOPE THAT THERE
WILL BE ADDITIONAL HEARINGS- I
HOPE THAT WILL BE A CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE THAT WE CAN. HAVE
BEFORE THE PUBLIC- AND HAVE THIS
AND HAVE MORE DISCUSSIONS ON
THIS AT THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
CONNECT. AT TO WILDFIRE
PREVENTION IT NEEDS TO COMMIT TO
INVESTING AND WATER STORAGE NEW
AND ADDITIONAL WATER STORAGE
NOW. AND GIVING DRIVERS A TAX
RELIEF AT THE PUMPS. I THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG-
RIVAS DO YOU HAVE A STATEMENT
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE ON YOUR
PRIORITIES. I'M SORRY NO PROBLEM
NOW THANK YOU OF YOU KNOW THIS
YEAR MY I HAVE FOCUSED ON
EXTREME HEAT I JUST CAME IN VERY
HOT LOTS OF PARTS OF OUR STATE.
OF OUR SUFFERING RIGHT FROM THE
HEAT AND I KNOW MISTER BLOOM THE
YOU'VE BEEN ALSO WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE OF YOU KNOW WE NEED. TO
DEVELOP PROGRAMS FOR I WAS JUST
TALKING TO SOMEONE ABOUT OUR
GREEN SCHOOLYARDS RIGHT TO HELP
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- GREEN AND ADD
MORE SHADE AND TREES AND GREEN
SPACE TO THESE PLAYGROUNDS THAT
KIDS HAVE TO GO OUT AND PLAY.
I'M YOU KNOW I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES WE HAVE VERY LITTLE-
OPEN SPACE AND VERY LITTLE
AVAILABLE- LOTS FOR PARKS SO FOR
US IT'S NOT AN OPTION WE HAVE TO
BE CREATIVE. AND FIND WAYS TO
ADD GREEN SPACE TO URBAN AREAS
AND YOU KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING I
WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR- BUT
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
WORK ON THIS BUDGET- AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE. TO WORK
WITH ALL OF YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO WILL THAT WE'VE TAKEN
TO VOTE AND IF YOU'D LIKE- WE
CAN HAVE YOU ADD ON NOW LIKE TO
CALL THIS- RIVAS I. AND THE
SECOND OPTION RIVAS. FIRST ONE
IS NOW SIX ZERO IN THE SECOND
ONE IS FOR TO THAT MEASURE
PASSES AS WELL. THANK YOU- THIS
IS NOT ONLY THE FINAL HEARING OF
THIS YEAR- FOR SUB THREE IT'S MY
FINAL HEARING AS CHAIR OF THE
SUB COMMITTEE AND I. WOULD LIKE
TO USE A OF MY FEW MOMENTS TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST DECADE THAT
I'VE BEEN CHAIR. AND THAT AYE
AYE UGH I BEGIN BY SAYING THESE
ARE JUST A FEW OF THE THINGS. OF
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE HAS BEEN TRULY
REMARKABLE IN THE BREADTH AND
THE- SPECIFICS OF THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED OVER TEN YEARS. WE
FIRST SECURED LASTING FUNDING
FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION RESPONSE
AND CREATED A PROGRAM TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS IN OUR MOST POLLUTED
COMMUNITIES. WE PROTECT OUR
STATE'S BIODIVERSITY INCLUDING
BUILDING WILDLIFE CORRIDORS AND
WE'VE BEGUN AN ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO PROTECTING OCEAN
MAMMALS. WE'VE LED THE NATION
AND THE WORLD IN ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES WE BUILT NEW LOCAL
PARKS AND EXPANDED ACCESS TO OUR
STATE PARKS. WITH PROVIDED
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR PLANTING TREES WE'VE
APPROPRIATED HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS FOR NATURAL SOLUTIONS
TO SEA LEVEL RISE WITH DEDICATED
FUNDING FOR REACHING OUR THIRTY
BY THIRTY CONSERVATION GOALS AS
WELL AS REDUCING IN RESPONDING
TO EXTREME HEAT. AND LAST YEAR
ALONE WE ADOPTED FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN CLIMATE INVESTMENTS
AND THIS YEAR THE GOVERNMENT
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY TWO BILLION
BRINGING THE TOTAL TO FORTY
SEVEN BILLION AS I MENTIONED
THIS LIST IS NOT EXHAUSTIVE. ARE
THERE ARE MANY MANY MORE
PARTICULARLY TRANSPORTATION OF
FUNDING- ENERGY FUNDING AND SO
MUCH MORE. BUT THERE ARE STILL
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SAY- WE DON'T- WE
DON'T STOP. A OF SOME OF THOSE
INCLUDE INVESTMENTS IN OUR AB
SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE HARDEST HIT BY AIR POLLUTION
. MORE MONEY FOR SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE INCLUDING HELPING
FARMERS TRANSITION TO ORGANIC
CROPS INVESTMENTS IN DM SAFETY
MORE LOCAL PARKS INCLUDING
DISABILITY FEATURES FOR CHILDREN
. AND ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS TO
PROTECT CRITICAL BIODIVERSITY
AND LAND AND OCEAN CONSERVATION
INCLUDING PROTECTING STEEL AT
DROUGHT EXPANDING KELP FORESTS
CLEANING UP DDT OFF THE COAST
AND EXPANDING WILDLIFE CORRIDORS
WITH CRITICAL ACQUISITIONS.
THERE'S STILL MORE TO BE DONE IN
THIS BUDGET. AND WE ARE- AB HAVE
FOR SEVERAL WEEKS LEFT IN THE
PROCESS AND THE THIS WALL AND
WITH A CRESCENDO IN JUNE AND I
HOPE TO SEE MANY OF THESE ITEMS
INCLUDED IN OUR FINAL BUDGET.
ONCE AGAIN- I WANT TO THANK OUR
BUDGET STAFF OF AND I THANK
THOSE WHO ARE. CURRENTLY HELPING
WITH THE BUDGET AND STAFFING
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE THREE BUT I
WANT TO ALSO THANK THOSE WHO
HAVE DONE SO OVER THE COURSE OF
THE YEARS PRECEDING SINCE I
BEGAN IN THOSE THREE INDIVIDUALS
ARE GABRIELLE MINDEL. SUSAN CHAN
AND FARAH BROCK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR EVERYTHING THAT ALL OF
YOU DO. NOW WERE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE MAY REVISE AND WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- A REVIEW IN THE
TRANSPORTATION LETTERS.
AND THEN IF YOU. THIS IS
LETTERS- THAT WOULD BE GREAT
WILL FOLLOW THAT WITH THE
PRESENTATION FROM ALEJO. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS MY NAME IS
THERESA CALVERT WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HERE AT MY COLLEAGUES
OR DO I GOT TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF KEY ITEMS FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION. AND I
WILL SPEAK TO THE ITEMS RELATED
TO THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AND
THE BROAD BASED RELIEF PROPOSAL
THAT WILL TURN IT OVER TO SERGIO
TO COVER KEY PROPOSALS AND THERE
IS A NATURAL RESOURCES
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGRICULTURE AND ENERGY. IN
ADDITION WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
DEPARTMENT AND AGENCY
REPRESENTATIVES HELP RESPOND TO
QUESTIONS FROM PLEASE NOTE THAT
SOME OF OUR REPRESENTATIVES ARE
ALSO IN A CONCURRENT HEARING SO
IF WE MAY HAVE TO GET BACK TO ON
SOME ITEMS ARE QUESTIONS
DEPENDING ON COVERAGE. I'M FIRST
UP IS TRANSFER. AT A HIGH LEVEL
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES THE
FOLLOWING NOTABLE CHANGES TO THE
TRANSPORTATION AREA. M. AS A
RESULT OF CALIFORNIA
ANTICIPATING RECEIVING ALMOST
40% MORE HIGHWAY FUNDING OVER
THE EXT FEW. FROM THE FEDERAL
AND- BILL THAT RECEIVED OVER THE
PREVIOUS FIVE YEAR PERIOD. NO
THE FIXED OF. SURFACE
TRANSPORTATION. THE MAYOR VIC
INCLUDE RESOURCES FOR THE
FOLLOWING. THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
SUPPORT PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM
DESIGNS AND OVERSEES THE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS ON THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM BASED ON
CALTRANS AS FIVE YOUR WORKLOAD
PRODUCTION. PROJECTION AN
INCREASE OF A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
MILLION FOR SIX HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX POSITIONS IS REQUESTED. M.
IN ADDITION PROGRAMS THAT EXPECT
TO SEE AN INCREASED WORKLOAD
INCLUDE MAINTENANCE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE TRAFFIC OPERATIONS
AND PLANNING AMONG OTHERS THE
MAY REVISION INCLUDES AN
INCREASE OF FIFTY MILLION FOR
TWO HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
POSITIONS ACROSS MULTIPLE
CALTRANS PROGRAMS. ALSO AS PART
OF THE M. GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
REQUEST M. THAT AGAIN WAS
INITIALLY PROPOSED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE HAVE THREE
NEW POSITIONS PROPOSED AT THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. THIS IS TO PROVIDED
TO OVERSIGHT OF PROGRAMS
IMPACTED BY THE INCREASED
FUNDING LEVELS. THE MAY REVISION
ALSO NEW TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
CONTRACTING OPTIONS. ON THERE'S
ALSO PROPOSED LANGUAGE WILL
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR. IN A
REGIONAL RAIL PROJECTS HELLO
CALTRANS TO PROVIDE ADVANCE
PAYMENTS TO LOCAL AUTHORITIES
FOR CERTAIN TRANSIT PROJECTS. AN
UPDATE CALTRANS IS RIGHT AWAY
AUTHORITY TO FACILITATE
BROADBAND INSTALLATION. AND AS
PART OF THE BROAD BASED RELIEF
PACKAGE THAT WAS. I'M PROPOSED
EARLIER THIS SPRING THE MAY
REVISION REFLECTS THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM THAT IS
IN ADDITION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR A TOTAL OF
ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
PROGRAM. THERE'S ALSO SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR GRANTS
TO TRANSIT AGENCIES TO PROVIDE
FREE TRANSIT FOR THREE MONTHS
THAT GRANT AMOUNT IS BASED ON
THE FAREBOX REPORTED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN BY THOSE AGENCIES.
REALLY FOUGHT PACKAGE ALSO
PROPOSES TO PARTICLE OF THE
THREE POINT 9% GENERAL FUND
PORTION OF THE DIESEL SALES TAX
FOR ONE YEAR. HOWEVER TRANSFERS
TO THE TRANSPORTATION ACCOUNTS
WILL BE FULLY FUNDED FOR THIS
WILL NOT IMPACT TRANSIT FUNDING.
THERE ALSO I VARIOUS REQUESTS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL AND DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES FOR VARIOUS WORKLOAD
ISSUES. THIS IS INCLUDING M.
FUNDING FOR OFFICE PROJECTS AS
WELL AS WORKERS COMPENSATION
COSTS. I MOVE ON TO THE BROAD
BASED RELIEF PROPOSAL M. ONE OF
THE MAIN COMPONENTS WOULD
PROVIDE A ONE TIME REFUND. OF
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS TO EACH
ELIGIBLE OWNER OF A REGISTERED
VEHICLE. THE PROPOSAL CAPS
NUMBER REBATES TO TWO PER
REGISTER VEHICLE OWNER FOR A
TOTAL OF EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS.
EXCLUDES FLEETS AND CORPORATE
OWNED VEHICLES. AND ALSO EXCLUDE
VEHICLES OVER A CERTAIN VALUE.
THIS BROAD BASED REFUND WOULD
RETURN AN ESTIMATED ELEVEN POINT
FIVE BILLION BACK TO TAXPAYERS.
THOSE ARE VERY HIGH LEVEL
DESCRIPTIONS OF TRANSPORTATION.
ISSUES I WOULD. BEER FOR
QUESTIONS AS WELL AS OUR TEAM
AND AT THIS POINT WILL TURN IT
OVER TO SERGIO FOR THE OTHER
AREAS. THANK YOU IN MARIN JR
MEMBERS THAT SURGE PART OF
FINANCE SONGS ARE OFF BY A
COVERING A FEW OF THE CROSS
PROPOSALS THAT GO ACROSS
MULTIPLE AGENCY LETTERS GOOD THE
IMPACT MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS AND
THEN I'LL GO INTO THE PACIFIC-
INDIVIDUALIZED- PROPOSALS FOR
SOME OF DEPARTMENTS THE FIRST
ALL COVER THE WATER RESILIENCE
AND DROUGHT A PROPOSAL SO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT INCLUDE
HISTORIC FIVE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLAR MULTI YEAR INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA WATER SYSTEMS TO
SUPPORT IMMEDIATE DROUGHT AND A
LONG TERM WATER RESILIENCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
ADDITIONAL DROUGHT RESILIENCE
INVESTMENT OF ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS- TO FOCUS ON DROUGHT
RELIEF AND ALSO PROMOTING WATER
CONSERVATION NOW GIVEN THE- OF
THE DROUGHT SINCE JANUARY THE
MAYOR VERSION DOES INCLUDE AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS INCLUDING
ALLOCATION OF THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION- DROUGHT
CONTINGENCY SET ASIDE THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S%
BUDGET- TO DO TWO THINGS. ONE
THE COMMUNITIES AND FISHER WALL
OF. IMMEDIATE IN AS A RESULT OF
EXTREME DROUGHT WHILE ALSO
CONTINUING TO ADVANCE- PROJECT
AND PROGRAMS THAT PREPARE TO THE
STATE TO BE MORE RESILIENT TO
FUTURE GROWTH- THIS INCLUDES
FUNDING. VERY DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS- WATER RECYCLING-
ADVANCING- WATER AND CLEAN WATER
PROJECTS AGRICULTURAL
CONSERVATION TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND RELIEF. GRANTS
TO- WATER JUST AND WATER.
SUPPORTING EMERGENCY DRINKING
WATER RESPONSE DATA AND WATER
CONSERVATION EDUCATIO CAMPAIGNS
AND ALSO ADDRESSING FISH AND
WILDLIFE ASSOCIATED IMPACTS-
WITHDRAWING CLIMATE CHANGE AMONG
MANY OTHER INVESTMENTS- THE
MAYOR VISION DOES ALSO INCLUDE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. IN TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX TO SERVE AS A MULTI
YEAR COMMITMENT TO PROMOTE
STRATEGIC WATER STORAGE PROJECTS
IN THE STATE THAT BENEFIT BOTH
WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY AND
ALSO THE ENVIRONMENT. AND THIS
WOULD BUILD ON THE TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS THAT- IS
ALREADY PROVIDED UNDER
PROPOSITION ONE FOR THE WATER
STORAGE INVESTMENT PROGRAM. NOW
MOVING ON TO THE CAP AND TRADE
SO GUY BUDGET PER. NINE HEARD
AND FOR SIX DOLLAR- VERY- THAT
DID DISK. CAP AND TRADE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THE REMISSION VEHICLES
AB SIX SEVENTEEN AND ALSO A
COMMUNITY AIR MONITORING- THE OF
FEBRUARY CAP AND TRADE AUCTION
RESULTED IN ADDITIONAL FOUR
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION. IN
REVENUES OF WHICH A HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION OUR
DISCRETIONARY- FOR THE MAY
REVISION SO THE MAJOR VISION
EYES IS THE THIS. FITNESS
REVENUES ACROSS TO- ONE IS A
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME TO
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF SATELLITES
LAUNCHED FROM OBSERVATION WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE WEEKLY
MEASUREMENTS- OF LARGE A METHANE
EMISSIONS IN THE STATE- TO ALSO
AND- HAS ENFORCEMENT KEEP. THE
DATA WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO
IDENTIFY THE SOURCE OF THE
COMMISSION- WORK PRO TO HOLD IN
ACCOUNTED FOR BY. AND ALSO THE
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS IN THE
ATMOSPHERE AND THEN THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL- TWENTY MILLION
PREVIOUSLY SEVENTEEN WHICH BRING
THAT TOTAL UP TO TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MILLION FOR A. B. SIX
SEVENTEEN. NOW MOVING ON THE
THEIR OLD- EMISSION
ACCELERATION. SO IN MARCH THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD PROPOSED
ACCELERATING ONE POINT SEVEN
FIVE BILLION- FROM THE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE INVESTMENTS TO
SUPPORT PATH IN YOUR VIEW CENTER
OF. CHARGE A FOR AND COMMUNITY
OPTION PROGRAMS AND THAT'S
PROPOSAL IS THE WITH. LAST WEEK
IN THE SUB COMMITTEE HERE. IN A
- THE ADMINISTRATION ON THAT
FELL. FOR THE MAYOR OF. AND
WE'RE PROPOSING THE MAY REVISION
OF THE DISH ACCELERATION UP BY
HUNDRED AND MILLION. AND IF THE%
TOTAL ACCELERATION TO TWO POINT
THREE BILLION FOR IS EMISSION
VEHICLE INVESTMENTS. THE
ACCELERATION IS PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON GREAT STRENGTH- BUS
FISCAL BUSES- EMERGING
OPPORTUNITIES AND ALSO THE
ASSOCIATED INFRASTRUCTURE.
RELATED TO THOSE INVESTMENTS- A
- THE FUNDING DOESN'T ABLE BOTH
THE CALL AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. TO INITIATE THE
PROCESS TEMPLE THE FUN SOONER
HELPED GREATER MARKET CERTAINTY
- ENABLES- CONSUMERS TO FIND
BETTER AND HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT
THERE ARE THE REBATES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. AVAIL FOR THE
CAN- THE EARLY PUBLIC INVESTMENT
ALSO PROVIDE A CLEAR SIGNAL TO
THE PRIVATE MARKET TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS AND ACCELERATE- THE
ACTIVITIES AND ALSO DOES PROVIDE
A- TANGIBLE RELIEF TO.
CALIFORNIANS THEY ARE FACING
RECORD. HIGH GAS PRICES. HOUSE
NOW MOVING ON TO AND- IN THE IN
THE MAYOR VISION. SO THE MAYOR
OF A DOES INCLUDE AN ADDITIONAL
EIGHT BILLION- INVESTMENTS TO
FURTHER THE STATE'S ENERGY FIFTY
RELIANCE. INCREASE RELIABILITY
AND AFFORDABILITY AND ALSO TO
ACCELERATE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
RESOURCES IN THE- TO ACHIEVE
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY
TRANSITION. AS WELL AS TO
PROVIDE DEBT RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS IMPACTED
BY THE CO NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
CLIMATE CHANGE CONTINUES TO
CAUSE UNPRECEDENTED STRESS ON
THE STATE ENERGY SYSTEMS
OPERATING RELIABILITY AND
PUTTING CALIFORNIA AT THE OF
ADDITIONAL OUT. GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES THE ADMINSTRATION
PULLED. FUNDING ACROSS VARIOUS
PROGRAMS THERE'S A FIVE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
STRATEGIC RELIABILITY WHICH
INCLUDES FOUR POINT TWO FOUR
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES. FOR
INVESTMENT IS STRATEGIC
RELIABILITY ASSETS AND NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION AT THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
FOR AND- ELECTRICITY BACK UP
ASSETS AND UTILITY SCALE ASSETS
. THE WILL BE A STATEWIDE
RESOURCE CAPABLE OF PROVIDING UP
TO FIVE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
AVAILABLE WHEN THE GREATEST-
THIS WILL INCREASE THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO WITHSTAND EXTREME AND
COINCIDENT EVENTS- BUT WILL NOT
TAKE THE PLACE OF A LONGSTANDING
OBLIGATIONS OF ALL LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES. TO PROCURE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES TO MAINTAIN
RELIABILITY. OF THE MAYOR VISION
ALSO FOR IS TO HER NINETY FIVE
MILLION OVER MULTIPLE YEARS- IT
FOR THE THIEF THE- IN DEVELOPING
DEMAND RESPONSE IN. LEAVE AFTER
WILL HELP ENERGY OF ON THE GRID
- DURING- PEAK ENERGY TIMES. THE
RULES ALL RECKONED THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL
STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR
ELECTRICITY BILLS AND PROVIDES
AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT TWO
BILLION IN RELIEF FOR THE
ELECTRIC UTILITY RATEPAYERS
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA REAR JUST
PAYMENT PROGRAM- TO HELP ADDRESS
A GROWING ENERGY BILLS FACED BY.
CALIFORNIA VESTER OD TO THE
RATEPAYER. THE MAYOR VISION ALSO
ROSES THIRTY MILLION TO HELP
COMMUNITIES AND TO BAY.
ORGANIZATION GAS TO REFILL TO
FACILITATE PART. IN THE CPUC
PROCESS AND ALSO INCLUDES THE
STATUTORY REVISIONS TO ALLOW
CPUC TO CONSIDER ADJUSTMENTS TO
ELECTRICITY RATES TO
PREDETERMINED STATES CHARGES
WITH CONSIDERATIONS OF LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS- THIS RATE
REFORM WILL REDUCE THE CHARGES
ATTACHED- TWO VOLUME OF
ELECTRICITY CONSUMED. HELP
CONTROL- REYES VOLATILITY AND
ALSO WILL ENABLE CREATION OF
BETTER PRICING THAT WILL ENHANCE
THE Y. ELECTRIFICATION EFFORTS-
ALSO ALONG WITH THE ENERGY IN
VISION PROPOSED. NINE HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION FOR THE PC TO
PROVIDE RESIDENTIAL SOLAR AND
STORAGE SYSTEM INCENTIVES
THROUGH THE SELF GENERATION
INCENTIVE PROGRAM INCLUDING FOR
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS- TO AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION AS INCLUDED-
TO ADVANCE ELECTRICITY
TRANSMISSION. INCLUDING THE FILE
AND SEE IF SUPPORT OF THE
STATE'S LIVE VALLEY VISION AND
THE NEED FOR A CLEAN FOR
MILITARIS E. FROM NEW GEO
THERMAL- RESOURCES IN THE
REGION. HAVE BEEN LAST WEEK- ON
THE ENERGY PACKAGE BUILDING ON
THE SUCCESS OF EPIC WHICH IS A
FIFTH PREMIER RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM. THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED- ONE
BILLION. FOR GRANTS TO COMPANIES
HEADQUARTERED IN CALIFORNIA WITH
A FOCUS ON DEVELOPING AND
COMMERCIALIZING NEW TECHNOLOGIES
THEY'LL HELP WITH THE OUR
CLIMATE AND CLEAN ENERGY GOALS.
FOR THAT COVERS THE VARIOUS KIND
OF CROSS CUTTING PACKAGES THAT-
THAT WE HAVE WITHIN THE MAYOR
VISION AND NOW MOVE ON TO SOME
INDIVIDUAL PROPOSALS- WITHIN
SOME OF THE DEPARTMENTS- IN THE
AGENCIES. SO THAT MOVING ON TO
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT WHAT ONE OF
THE PROPOSALS- RELATED TO THAT
CALIFORNIA CLIMB INFORMATION
SYSTEM. FOR THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES EIGHTEEN POINT THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE TIME-
FOR NATURI THROUGH THE AGENCY
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVE.
TO SUPPORT THE PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT OF PHASE ONE OF THE
NEW- CUT CLIMATE HI CALIFORNIA
CLIMB INFORMATION SYSTEM ALSO
THE CHALCIS KALFUS WILL BE A
CLOUD BASED SYSTEM THAT WILL
PROVIDE A STATE AGENCY THE WITH
A CLOSE TO REAL TIME CLIMATE
DATA. AND DATA MANAGEMENT
PRODUCTS TO BETTER- HAVE BEEN
HAVE BETTER CLIMATE MITIGATION
RESILIENCE AND ADAPTATION. TO SO
THE STATE CAN BETTER ACHIEVE ITS
CLIMATE BITE EVER GOALS
CURRENTLY STAGING GATHER AND
MANAGE CLIMATE DATA IN THE FILE. OF MATTER WITH SOME DEPARTMENT
VIEWS LIFE IN CLIMATE DATA THAT
IS TEN YEARS OR OLDER TO FOUR
MEGABIT DECISIONS WHILE OTHERS
ARE USING THE LATEST REMOTE
SENSING DATA. OUT SO CALPERS
WILL IMPROVE THE INTER AGENCY
COLLABORATION WHILE ALLOWING
WITH THE AGENCIES TO CONTINUE
DEVELOPING PRODUCTS AND ALSO
LEVERAGE THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ADVANCE THEIR CLIENT OBJECTIVES
. NOW MOVING ON TO THE
CALIFORNIA AIR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- PROPOSED SIGNIFICANT NEW
INVESTMENTS TO BOTH CONTINUE TO-
BUILD FOREST AND WILDFIRES ILYIN
STATEWIDE. AND ALSO EXPAND THE
STATE'S WILDFIRE RESPONSE
CAPACITY AND THE MAYOR VISION
DOES THE BUILD ON THESE EFFORTS
WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
SUPPORT EXPANDED FIRE CREWS AND
AIR ATTACK OPERATIONS-
SPECIFICALLY THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES EIGHTY THREE POINT ONE
MILLION GENERAL FUND. TO AUGMENT
CALIFORNIA FIRE PROTECTION
RESOURCES THROUGH DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. GIVEN THE
CURRENT GOD DROUGHTCONDITIONS
INCREASING FIRE SEVERITY AND
SIZE AND ALSO THE DECLINING IN
MATH IN MAY CAMP POPULATION. THE
MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED FIFTY POINT
TWO MILLION AND FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE- OPPOSITION FOR
CALIFORNIA- OR TO ENHANCE THEIR
CAPABILITIES TO MEET THE DEMAND
OF WALDEN FIRE FIGHTING IN A
CHANGING CLIMATE. THIS INCLUDES
A HUNDRED AND FOUR MILLION AND
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
POSITIONS FAVE IN OVER MULTIPLE
. TO PROVIDE CAL FIRE NECESSARY
STAFFING ASSOCIATED WITH- A FEW
OF THE GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET FIRE
CREW PROPOSALS. THIRTY SEVEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION- AND THIRTY
FIVE POINT SIX ONGOING A HUNDRED
NINETY PETITIONS TO ENHANCE.
IMPROVE OPERATIONAL
EFFECTIVENESS AND PROVIDE
CRITICAL ADMINISTRATIVE AND
PROGRAM SUPPORT NECESSARY TO
STAYING CAL FIGHTERS DIRECT
MISSION FUNCTIONS. IN AN
INCREASING COMPLEX ENVIRONMENT
AND THEN EIGHT MILLION GENERAL.
FUND AND THIRTY FOUR FOR- FOR A
VERY LEVEL STAFF ASSOCIATED
WITH- SOME OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT THAT ARE PROVIDED- IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDING.
THE IRA CAL COPTERS AND THEN THE
TEN EXCLUSIVE USE HELLA TAKERS-
THING ON WITH WITH CAL FIRE JUST
THE A AND A MAJOR VERSION OF THE
ON THE WALL FIRE FORCE
RESILIENCE- PACKAGE- THE MAYOR
VISION DOES- PROPOSED TO
ACCELERATE EIGHTY MILLION- IN
TO. TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SO
SEATED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- WILDFIRE PACKAGE AND
THEN ALSO REQUEST AN ADDITIONAL
SIXTY POSITIONS ACROSS- THREE
DEPARTMENTS CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD AND STATE WATER
BOARD TO ADDRESS SOME HIGH PARTY
NEEDS- CENTRAL TO THE PLAN. OF
THE TWO TWENTY TO AND FOREST
RESILIENCE PACKAGE AT THE
POSITIONS WILL BE FUNDED- WITHIN
THE ALLOCATIONS OF THAT PACKAGE. MOVING ON TO THE PART OF RATES
. IN ADDITION TO THE MANY IN FOR
PRETTY W. R. ACROSS THE AND
DROUGHT INVESTMENTS- ALSO.
PROPOSING AN ADDITIONAL- THIRTY
THREE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT THE COMPLETION
OF TWO EXISTING PROJECTS TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF FLOODING A
LOSS OF LIFE PROPERTY AND MAJOR
MED DAMAGES- IN URBAN AREAS IN
THE CENTER VALLEY. ADD THIS
FUNDING CONTINUES TO ADDRESS
OBLIGATIONS AND THAT LEVERAGE
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL FUNDING-
RELATED TO FLOOD. MOVING ON TO
THE DEPARTMENT AND PARKS AND
RECREATION THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL EIGHTY
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION. TO
INCREASE ECHO BLACKS TO STAY
PARK. THROUGHOUT THE FALL ONE
TIME INVESTMENT. OF FIFTEEN
MILLION TO X. EXISTING OUTDOOR.
WHICH AND ACTIVE. FOR K. THROUGH
TWELVE STUDENTS. FOR MILLION FOR
CA. OF A NEW BILL CENTER- AND
OTHER AND- PROVEN THAT CURL
ALLEN. STATE HISTORIC PARK.
FIFTEEN MILLION FOUR- THE
ARTNER PARKS PARTNER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AMERICA AMERICAN
MUSEUM- THAT TO BETTER TELL THE
INCLUSIVE STORY OF LIKE HISTORY
IN STATE PARKS. AND ALSO
THIRTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION TO
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF PARK PASSES
MADE AVAILABLE THROUGH A PILOT
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE STATE PARK
PASSES. UP FOR CHECK OUT AT LOW
LIVE. MOVING ON THE STATE
CORSICA- ONE HIGHLIGHT ONE
PROPOSAL WHERE THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
CONSERVANCY FOR THE ACQUISITION
REAL PROPERTY THESE GRANTS
EFFORTS IN BUILDING CLIMATE
RESILIENCE THROUGH THE
ACQUISITION OF- CRITICAL
SHORELINE PROPERTIES TO PROTECT
NATURAL RESOURCES THAT PROVIDE
FOR PUBLIC ACCESS AND ALSO
IMPLEMENT THE STATE'S NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS AGENDA. NOW
MOVING ON TO THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION- AND PROPOSAL
RELATED TO THE LITHIUM VALLEY SO
THEIR VISION PROPOSES-
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES TO ADVANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S LITHIUM VALUE VISION
AND THIS INCLUDES FIVE MILLION
TO THE POOR PLANNING AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. IN
IMPERIAL COUNTY RELATED TO THE
GEOTHERMAL DEVELOPMENT AND
LITHIUM EXTRACTION AND
PROCESSING IN THE FAULT OF THE
REGION. A FIFTEEN MILLION PER
YEAR FOR THREE YEARS FOR A SALES
TAX EXCLUSION AT THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY AND ADVANCED
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. AT
EIGHTY MILLION TO EXPAND
TRAINING AT THE SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY PROBABLY CENTER IN
THE IMPERIAL VALLEY. THIS
PROPOSAL ALSO ADVANCES THE A
MAJOR COMMUNITY PRIORITY BY
PROVIDING FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND RESIDENTS TO BENEFIT FROM
THE DEVELOPMENT AND EXTRACTION
OF LITHIUM ESTABLISHING BY
ESTABLISHING- TECH FOR TONS OF
LITHIUM EXTRACTION. PLACING AND
FEE REQUIREMENTS ON THAT THE
EXTRACTION ACTIVITIES. AND
PROVIDING FUNDS TO CONTRIBUTE TO
THE MAINTENANCE OPERATIONS AND
RESTORATION THE SOLVENCY AND
GRANTS TO SUPPORT COMMUNITIES IN
THE REGION. NOW MOVING ON TO- A
FEW INVESTMENTS WITHIN THE-
CALIFORNIA BY MENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY- TO WE WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES THAT CONTROL- THE
MAYOR VISION INCLUDES FORTY
SEVEN MILLION- ONE TIME. TO
UNDERTAKE CLEANUP ACTIVITIES
NEEDED TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THE ENVIRONMENT FROM
ELEVATED CONCENTRATION OF LEAD
LEVELS OF FOUND DURING THE CLEAN
UP IN THE TOWN OF GREENVILLE
FOLLOWING THE DIXIE FIRE- THIS
ACTION IS NEEDED SO THAT
PROPERTY OWNERS CAN SAFELY
REBUILD. AND RESIDENTS CAN
RETURN SAFELY RETURNED WITH
SIGNIFICANT REDUCED RISK OF
EXPOSURE TO THIS CONTAMINATION.
AND THEN THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES- FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN IN
NINETEEN POSITIONS- IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE WHICH THEN
SHIFTS TO FIVE POINT NINE
MILLION HEATHER IS WASTE
FACILITY THE COW IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND I'M GOING. TO
ADDRESS THE INCREASED WORKLOAD
RELATED TO THE TIRTIETH
ENVIRONMENTAL VIOLATIONS CAUSED
BY THE METATRADER FACILITY
OPERATIONS. AND THEN WE ON TO
TWENTY ABOUT THAT TO HIGHLIGHT
WITHIN THE THEY WATERY CONTROL
BOARD. THE MAYOR VISION INCLUDE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME-
CORONAVIRUS FISCAL RECOVERY
FUNDS- FOR- SEE IF THE
DEPARTMENT COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND DEVELOPMENT. TO SUPPORT- THE
AVAILABLE FUNDS AND ALL ARGUMENT
THE BILL MEANT AVAILABLE FUNDING
FOR THE FEDERAL LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLD WATER OF. PROGRAM THAT
THE PROVISION OF MADE POSSIBLE
BY A REVERSION OF AN EQUIVALENT
AMOUNT OF FUNDING- FROM THE
STATE WATER BOARD ASSOCIATED
WITH- A RESEARCH FUNDING
PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT- WE ANTICIPATED
TO BE APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SIX MILLION IN
SAVINGS FROM THE WATER PORTS
PROGRAM. AT THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION OF THIS WILL BE FOR A
PURPOSE STUFF FOR ALSO WATER
RIDGES BUT WITHIN A FEW OF THESE
EXISTING PROGRAM. AND THEN JUST
LASTLY- HIGHLIGHT ONE OF THE
GOALS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE- WHICH IS A
CONTINUATION OF THE BE SAFE
PROGRAM AND ALSO- APRIL A P. R.
E. P. TRAILER BILL. THE MAYOR
VISION INCLUDES ONGOING GENERAL
FUND AND PUTTING AGRICULTURE
FUND TO CONTINUE OPERATING THE
STATE WIDE BE SAFE PRO- TO
PROMOTE AN PROTECT THE SAFE.
HEALTHY FOOD SUPPLY THROUGH THE
PROTECT OF COMMERCIAL HONEY.
THIS RICK ALSO INCLUDES. CHANGES
TO WHAT'S RIGHT THE DEPARTMENT.
TO INCREASE THE AND- A PRAIRIE.
FEE TO THE POOR ESSENTIAL
PROGRAM ACTIVITIES BY THE
COUNTIES INCLUDING THE
ENFORCEMENT OF EXISTING LAWS
INTENDED TO PROTECT BE CALL
NEEDS FROM VARIOUS THREATS. SUCH
THEFT CALL ME- WEAKNESS LOSS-
AND THERE IS- AS MACABRE ALSO
MENTIONED VERY OTHER- WORKLOAD-
TECHNICAL ROLES WITHIN THE
AGENCY THAT WE WANTED TO THE
COVER BUT- HAVE FOLKS AVAILABLE
ONLINE TO ALSO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ON THOSE THAT THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. A. A
PRACTICE HOW LONG DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE PRESENT WILL BE MAYBE
MINUTES OKAY PERFECT- I BONE-
ASK OF SECRETARY CROWFOOT IS
ONLY AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS UP UNTIL SO I THINK WE
CAN FIT THIS ALL IN I DO WANT TO
WELCOME- ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN-
DID YOU HAVE A STATEMENT YOU'D
LIKE TO MAKE REGARDING YOUR
PRIORITIES- VERY GOOD- AND-
WE'VE TAKEN TO VOTES WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ADD ON AT THIS TIME.
MISTER MULLIN. WOULD YOU LIKE
THAT WE'VE TAKEN TO VOTES WOULD
YOU LIKE TO ADD ON AT THIS TIME
THANK. FOR THE FIRST MOTION
MULLIN. THE SECOND MOTION MULLIN
. THE FIRST ONE IS NOW SEVEN
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES IN THE
SECOND ONE IS FIVE TO THAT
MEASURE ALSO PASSES THANK YOU
AND I WILL HEAR FROM THE ELIO
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RETAILERS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME- MY COMMENTS WERE BE
BRIEF AND HIGH LEVEL WE'RE STILL
LOOKING AT THE INDIVIDUAL
PROPOSALS HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
AND YOUR STAFF IN THE COMING
WEEKS AS YOU DAYS. WEEKS AS YOU
WERE MAKING YOUR FINAL DECISION-
AS YOU COULD TELL FROM THE TWO
DIFFERENT LENGTHS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- PROPOSALS
BUT PRESENTATIONS THAT YOU JUST
HEARD IT IS A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
STORY WITH TRANSPORTATION AS
COMPARED TO RESOURCE AS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION- THERE
AREN'T TON OF KIND OF LARGE NEW
TRANSPORTATION PROPOSALS
INCLUDED IN THE MAIL REVISION-
AND THOSE THAT ARE MY WITH TO
EARLY OR OTHER OR SO PROPOSALS-
AS A NOTED. THERE'S THEM THAT
JUST A FIVE MILLION FOR ACTOR
TRANSPORTATION THAT IS KIND OF
RELATED TO WHAT WAS BEFORE YOU
IN JANUARY- THEY QUITE A NUMBER
OF POSITION. ROUGHLY A THOUSAND
NEW POSITIONS PROPOSED AT
CALTRANS WHICH ARE TO IMPLEMENT
THAT FEDERAL NEW FEDERAL
PRACTICE BACK AND- BROADBAND
MIDDLE MILE PACKAGE SO THAT
THAT'S PRETTY SIGNIFICANT BUT
THOSE ARE PRETTY MAJOR
UNDERTAKINGS- MULTI YEAR
UNDERTAKING SO THE STATUS IS
APPROACHING- THERE ALSO SOME
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE PROPOSED
RELATED TO EMPLOYEE. OF THE I.
HA WHICH WE WOULD HIGHLIGHT FOR
YOU- SOME SOME COMPONENTS OF
THAT SAME MINOR SOME SEEM
POTENTIALLY A LITTLE BIT MORE
SIGNIFICANCE THAT SOMETHING YOU
MIGHT WANT TO THINK ABOUT
WHETHER YOU WANT A LITTLE MORE
TIME. TO CONSIDER THOSE TRAILER
BILL PROVISIONS- AND THEN AS
NOTED THERE ARE SOME PIECES TIED
TO THE GOVERNOR'S LARGER FISCAL
RELIEF PACKAGE AS WELL AND BOTH
THREE FUNDS THROUGH THE DMV- AND
AS WELL AS ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNDING FOR THE DMV EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION- ASSOC WITH THAT
PROPOSAL AND SEVEN WHO AND FIFTY
MILLION FOR TRANSIT SO WITH ALL
OF THESE I THINK ARE ARMY
MESSAGE ON THAT. IS BECAUSE THEY
ARE SO. TO THINK OF THE MAYOR.
PER IN CON. OF YOUR
TRANSPORTATION. A PACKAGE
DECISIONS- AND MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE DECISIONS ALIGN WITH EACH
OTHER. ON THE RESOURCES SIDE
THERE IS A LOT- A LOT OF FUNDING
MAJOR INCREASES NEARLY ALL ONE
TIME. SOME IS FOCUSED ON
IMMEDIATE- PRESSING NEEDS THINGS
LIKE DROUGHT WILDFIRES AND
POTENTIAL ENERGY SHORTAGES THE
THAT WE MAY SEE THIS SUMMER. AND
SOME. QUITE A BIT OF IT FOCUSES
ON LONGER TERM AT- CHALLENGES
AND STATE GOALS LIKE ENERGY-
DECARBONISATION AS WELL AS WATER
RELIABILITY. SO OVERALL WE THINK
THE GOVERNOR'S FOCUSES ON A
REASONABLE SET OF ISSUES WE
THINK THERE'S MERIT IN FOCUSING
ON CLIMATE RELATED CHALLENGES WE
THINK THERE'S MERIT IN A- HAVING
A MIX OF SHORT AND LONGER TERM
ACTIVITIES- AS WELL AS FOCUSING
ON ONE TIME RATHER THAN GONE
GOING. ACTIVITIES BECAUSE- OF
SOME OF THE FUTURE BUDGET
UNCERTAINTIES SO JUST A MOMENT
ON THAT. IT THE OVERALL APPROACH
YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU THIS YEAR IS
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT BECAUSE
OF THIS NEW EMERGING ISSUE OF
THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT
FOR SAL. CONSTRAINTS ACCORDING
TO THE CONSTITUTION IS A NEED TO
SPEND A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
FUNDING ON WHAT ARE CONSIDERED
SALIX GLUTAMYL ACTIVITIES OR TAX
REFUNDS SO AB. ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE EXCLUDABLE FROM THAT LIMIT
OR THINGS LIKE CAPITAL OUTLAY.
AND EMERGENCY SPENDING SO YOU'VE
GOT QUITE A BIT OF THAT IN THIS
SUB COMMITTEE- BUT THEN THERE
ARE ALSO PROPOSALS THAT ARE THAT
ARE SUBJECT TO THE LIMIT. I WE
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU THAT
WE THINK THERE'S ABOUT THREE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
UNADDRESSED SELL REQUIREMENTS IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED. WE
STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT YOU- DO
NOT PASS A BUDGET THAT DOESN'T
ADDRESS THOSE ROOT. IN PART
BECAUSE OF WHAT IT SETTING FOR
BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE. AT TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS AB TO HIGHLIGHT FOR
YOU. AND KIND OF TWO PARTS ONE
IS RELATED TO THE SOUTH WE SEE
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT SALVAR
FIREMAN'S INTO THREE TWENTY FOUR
ABOUT TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS IS
OUR CURRENT ESTIMATE. AND WE'RE
NOT FORECASTING THE SIZE OF THE
SURPLUS THAT YOU HAVE RIGHT NOW
WE'RE ONLY FORECASTING ABOUT A
TWO BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS SO WE
THINK YOU MAY FACE A REALLY BIG
CHALLENGE AND HOW YOU ADDRESS
THOSE REQUIREMENTS IN BUDGET
YOUR PLUS ONE. ONE WAY TO DO TO
PREPARE FOR THAT IS TO PUT MORE
FUNDING AND RESERVES SO TO THE
DEGREE YOU CAN LOOK AT YOUR KIND
OF NON SALLY EXCLUDABLE
ACTIVITIES. AND TRY AND FIND
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND THAT SIDE
OF THE BUDGET TO PUT INTO
RESERVES WE THINK IT WILL PUT
YOU IN A BETTER POSITION- COMING
TO BUDGET. PLUS ONE. ALL WORSE
SOME PRETTY CONCERNING SIGNS OF
A- RECESSION ON THE HORIZON- SO
WE ALSO THINK THAT THAT IS YET
ANOTHER REASON TO. GIVEN THAT
UNCERTAINTY TO TRY AND PUT
YOURSELF IN A BETTER POSITION.
SO THE STORE ON ON YOUR BY
THINKING ABOUT THE EXCLUDABLE
ACT AND THEN EXCLUDABLE IS SLOW
DIFFERENT- BUT OVERALL WE
CONTINUE TO STAY FOCUSED ON YOUR
PRIORITIES IN YOUR PRIORITIES
MAY BE DIFFERENT THAN THE
GOVERNOR'S AS AS WAS EVEN NOTED
EARLY AT THE BEGINNING OF THE-
YOU MAY WANT TO SPEND MORE ON.
WILDLIFE ARE ON WATER STORAGE-
AND LESS ON SOME THE GOVERNOR'S
PRIORITY SO USED YOU ALWAYS HAVE
THAT. TO MAKE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS
BOTH ON THE EXCLUDABLE SIDE AS
WELL AS THE NON EXCLUDABLE SIDE.
SOME OTHER CONSIDERATIONS WITH
THAT SUGGEST THINKING ABOUT OUR
CAPACITY FOR DE. AND LOCALS TO
IMPLEMENT THESE PROGRAMS
ESPECIALLY GIVEN LARGE
INVESTMENTS RECENTLY- IF THERE
ARE NEW. NEW PER. ESPECIALLY ON
THE NON X. SIDE THAT ARE
PROPOSED ME- HAVE A MUCH HIGHER
WE WOULD SEE HAVE A HIGHER FOR
CAN. WE TO THOSE ARE NOT SPENT
GIVEN THE TRADE OFFS- TIMING HOW
QUICKLY DO YOU NEED TO MAKE SOME
OF THESE DECISIONS- SPECIAL ON
THE TRAILER BILL SIDE BUT BUT
ALSO FOR SOME OF THESE LARGE
INVESTMENTS- WHAT. DO YOU NEED
TO DECIDE THE NEXT FEW WEEKS AND
WHAT COULD TAKE EITHER A FEW
MONTHS THIS SUMMER OR MAYBE
ABOUT DEFERRING SOME DECISIONS
UNTIL NEXT YEAR- WE SUGGEST
THINKING ABOUT REPORTING
LANGUAGE AND EVALUATION
ESPECIALLY FOR SOME OF THE NEW
PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT HE WHAT. WE'RE
GETTING FROM OUR STATE
EXPENDITURES- AND TO INFORM
FUTURE INVESTMENTS. AND THEN
FINALLY JUST A COMMENT ABOUT THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN-
MENTIONED WE DO THINK THERE IS.
OPPORTUNITY TO USE G. JEFF AND
GENERAL FUND STRATEGICALLY IN
PART TO HELP WITH SOME OF THE
CELL REQUIREMENTS THINKING ABOUT
WHICH ACTIVITIES ARE FUNDED WITH
EACH FUND SOURCE SO WE'RE HAPPY
TO HELP YOU WITH THAT- WE ALSO
THINK THERE IS ADDITIONAL D. G.
R. F. AVAILABLE BEYOND WHAT'S IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE WE THINK
THERE'S ABOUT. BASED ON OUR
HIGHER REVENUE ESTIMATES ABOUT
ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED MILLION YOU
MIGHT HAVE AVAILABLE TO SPEND-
ON DISCRETIONARY ACTIVITIES.
WITH THAT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND SOME OF. MY
COLLEAGUES ARE ONLINE AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF THE WE
PROCEED TO QUESTIONS I HAVE A
QUICK STATEMENT I'D LIKE TO MAKE
ABOUT. OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS ON THE- CLEAN ENERGY.
WELL I AGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR
THAT. ACCELERATING ADOPTION OF
CLEAN ENERGY. AND PREVENTING
DISRUPTIONS ARE AT TOP AND
URGENT PRIORITY- OF. ALL
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE A CHANCE TO
WEIGH IN. ON THE DIFFICULT
CHOICES THAT WE FACE. TO MEET
THOSE GOALS THIS YEAR. HI HOW
HARD EVERYONE'S WORKING TO TRY
AND GET THIS DONE. GIVEN THE
URGENCY. BUT IT JUST SEEMS TO ME
THAT WITHOUT PUBLIC INPUT. I
DON'T SEE HOW WE CAN GET IT
RIGHT. I'M ONE OF SEVERAL
MEMBERS THAT HAVE ASKED THE
SPEAKER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A HEARING ON THIS FALL PER
. BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY IS WILLING
TO CONSIDER IT AS A BUDGET
ACTION NOT EASILY THAT HEARING
IS NOT TODAY. AND SEEMS UNLIKELY
BEFORE JUNE FIFTEENTH BUT I'M
HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL GET THE
TRAILER BILL IN TIME FOR US TO
POSSIBLY CONSIDER ACTIONS. AS
EARLY AS BEFORE SUMMER RECESS.
NOW WILL MOVE TO MEMBER
QUESTIONS. AND JOB OF FIRST LET
ME ASK IF ANYONE HAS QUESTIONS
RELATED TO DROUGHT- BECAUSE
AGAIN US SECRETARY CROWFOOT IS
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW BUT HE NEEDS
TO LEAVE BY ELEVEN OTHER. ANY
QUESTIONS ON THAT TOPIC MR FONG. THIS IS WE HAVE THE SECRETARY
ON- ON THE- ON- ZERO MIGHT HAVE
. THE FIRST AND BY THE WAY IF
YOU HAVE OTHER QUESTIONS- AND
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE LIMITED TO
DROUGHT ABSOLUTELY- LET ME JUST
CONFIRM SOME NUMBERS FIRST SO
THAT IT TO THE L. A. OUT SETTING
ASIDE PROP ONE BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THAT. THAT WAS
ALREADY THAT WAS ALREADY IN
PLACE. CONNECT THIS UP. BUDGET
THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING. HOW MUCH
IS IN THIS BUDGET IN THE FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR FOR ABOVE GROUND
WATER STORAGE- THERE AREN'T ANY
SPECIFIC ALLOCATION SPECIFICALLY
FOR ABOVE GROUND STORAGE THERE
IS FUNDING FOR- SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT- PROJECTS
THAT IS. TAG I'VE WAS IN JANUARY
FEELS LIKE A LONG DAY AGO BUT I
IT FIFTEEN IF I REMEMBERING MR I
CAN HELP. AT TO SPECIFICALLY TO
WERE ON BELOW GROUND STORAGE-
BUT ARE NO OUT BUT FOR ABOVE
GROUND OKAY SO THEN LET ME ASK
AS I. A AND THAT'S ONE TWO FIVE
TWENTY SIX THE SUCH OF THE BY A
MAY RISE I UNDERSTAND THERE IS
STOOD WATER. AND OF FIVE AND
MILLION. UP CAN YOU. I GUESS
TELL ME WHAT THAT. IS YEAH WELL
TAKE YOUR MUCH MEMBER FOR THE
QUESTION AND APPRECIATE. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE- AND
THANK TERRIBLE FOR. THAT YOU'VE
DONE- FOR. NOW TO RESOURCE IN
FOR OF THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
YOU KNOW A LOT OF THE WE'VE- CAN
DIRECT TO INVEST THAT YOU'VE
CHAMPION THE SUBCOMMITTEE
CHAMPION. SO THANK YOU I THANK
YOU COMMITTEE. OP SO OFTEN
WHENEVER FONG JUST WANT TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE CONTEXT FOR ALL
WHO ARE WATCHING- CALIFORNIA
VOTERS PASSED PROPOSITION ONE-
WHICH PROVIDES WELL OVER TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OF FUNDING. FOR
STORY PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE-
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO.
CONTINUE TO. IN STORAGE BOTH
SMART ABOVEGROUND STORAGE AND
THE LOWER STORE WERE CHARGING
OUR AQUIFERS. AND SO- THOSE PROP
ONE PROJECTS WHICH NOW TOTAL
SEVEN PROJECTS. BRIEF SURFACE
STORAGE PROJECTS AND FOR
UNDERGROUND BURKE PROJECTS- WILL
DELIVER TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION
ADDITIONAL ACRE FEET OF SO.
WHICH IS A CO TO ABOUT TWO AWFUL
LAKE RESERVOIRS SIGNIFICANT OF
THE SUPPLY. ONE OF THOSE
PROJECTS IS OUR SITES RESERVOIR
WHICH IS RECEIVED A LOT OF.
BECAUSE IT HOLDS GREAT POTENTIAL
TO CAPTURE WATER IN WET YEARS
FOR USE IN DRIER OP LIKE. LIKE-
THE YEAR WERE EXPERIENCE. THE
GOOD NEWS IS I'M ON THOSE SEVEN
. IS THERE ARE MOVING FORWARD
OUR WATER COMMISSION IN OUR
AGENCY HAS MADE CLEAR THAT WE'RE
FOCUSED ON DOING WHATEVER WE
NEED TO DO WITH THAT I THE STATE
TO HELP THOSE MOVE FORWARD.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS MORE
RECENTLY DIRECTED US TO BE EVEN
MORE PROACTIVE TO WORKING WITH
THOSE SEVEN PROJECTS TO
IDENTIFY. HOW ELSE CAN WE
ACCELERATE THOSE PROJECTS.
GETTING DONE GIVEN CURRENT
DROUGHT CONDITIONS. SPECIFICALLY
THERE'S DISCUSSION IN THE MAY
REVISE OF FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN BUDGET YEAR TWENTY
FIVE. TWENTY SIX. OR AUGMENT. OF
SUPPLY FOR. I IN THE PROP I
SHOULD SAY. SPECIFICALLY ON THE
THOSE PROJECTS I IN THE COSTS
GIVE IN- INFLATION- WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THEY THE- COST OR
THAT FUNDING IT IS IN HEAVEN TO
BILLS PROJECT MOVING TO RIGHT.
BUT WE DO THINK THAT BY ON A
MILLION DOLLAR IN OUT. I COULD
VERY WELL BE HELPFUL AS PROJECTS
MOVE TOWARDS FRUITION. THANK YOU
TO THE L. A. L. IS THERE
ANYTHING IN THE MAYOR VISION
THAT YOU CAN SEE THAT
ACCELERATES AND THOSE PROJECTS.
HOT NOT EXPLICITLY NO OKAY. IN
THE WHAT PREVENTION PIECE LET ME
JUST CONFIRM THESE NUMBERS- THE
LAST LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATED
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR AWHILE FOR PREVENTION- AND
THE- CHAMBER. THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET AND I THINK THE
MAYOR VISION HAS ONE FOR TWO
BILLION OVER YEARS SO THE OF
FINANCE- THAT MEANS THERE'S SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION THIS YEAR
THIS CURRENT. BUDGET THAT WE'RE
DEBATING- YES THE THIRD RECORD
PART OF FINANCE- SO BASICALLY
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
WAS ONE POINT TWO BILLION OVER
TO FISCAL YEAR- AND LAST YEAR-
THOSE ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION- WHICH TECHNICALLY WITH
OVER TWO FIFTY YEARS BECAUSE- OF
IT WITH TWENTY TWENTY ONE. PART
ABLE TO ONE TWENTY TWO AND ALSO
JUST KIND OF POINT OUT THAT-
THEY HAVE MULTI YOUR SPENDING
AUTHORITY WITHIN WITHIN THE
FUNDING FOR SOME OF IT DOES
TAKE. SOME TIME TO SPEND ALL
APPROPRIATED SAY WE HAD A PRETTY
KIND OF A LARGE AMOUNT OF
PROBATE LAST YEAR SOME OF IT
WILL TAKE SOME TIME BUT
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT WE'RE PUTTING
AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT TWO
BILLION. WHICH EQUALS THE TOTAL
OF TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION WHEN
YOU COMBINE LAST YEAR'S AND THIS
YEAR'S INVESTMENT WHICH OF THE
PRETTIEST DARKENED SO HOW MUCH
IS LEFT TO SPENT. HOW MUCH IS.
AWHILE BY PREVENTION I CERTAINLY
WANT TO APPLAUD AND- ANNA
DOLLARS AT THAT THE- CAL
FIGHTER. THAT RESPONSE SIDE I
THAT'S IMPORTANT BUT ON THE JUST
THE PREVENTION SIDE- HOW MUCH IS
NOT. A INSERTED COVERED EACH OF
THESE FEDERAL JOB AND IF YOU IF
YOU LIKE TO. CAPTURE WE CAN DO
YOU THOSE SPECIFIC NUMBERS AND
WE'RE GLAD TO REPORT THAT AN
UPDATE ON THE SPEND. OF FUNDS
APPROPRIATED FOR WILDFIRE
RESILIENCY AT LAST YEAR IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. I AVAILABLE ONLINE
AND WE'RE UPDATING THAT-
PERIODICALLY AT THE DIRECTION OF
THE LEGISLATURE. HI AND THAT WAS
REALLY FOCUSED ON ENSURING
ACCOUNTABILITY WHAT WE HEARD
FROM THE LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR
IS. WE NEED TO GET THESE DOLLARS
WORKING AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
TO SCALE UP OUR WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE EFFORTS. THAT IS
THESE PROACTIVE ACTIONS THAT ARE
SUPPORTING. RESPONSE BUT PLACE.
BEFORE FIRESTAR. TO GO NEWS IS
THINK THE LEDGES TO GO. FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION WAS OUT.
IN EARLY. FUNDING IN LAST APRIL
EVEN BEFORE THE BUDGET PROCESS.
THAT FUNDING MATERIALIZED OVER
FIVE PROJECTS THAT ARE UNDERWAY
I HAVE SOME INITIAL PHASE
COMPLETED- THAT HAVE MADE A
DIFFERENCE EVEN THE LAST
WILDFIRE SEASON CERTAINLY IN
THIS WILDFIRE SEASON. AND THEN
THAT ADDITIONAL EIGHT SOME ODD
MILLION. EXCEPT ARE BEGINNING
THIS CUT THIS BUDGET YEAR ALSO
BEING SPENT- MR LAWRENCE
CORRECTED THAT WE ARE REALLY
FOCUSED ON BUILDING AND
MAINTAINING A PIPELINE- FUNDING.
FOR REGIONAL PRIORITIES REGIONAL
PROJECTS OR REGIONALLY
PRIORITIZE. TO WE HAVE THANKS TO
YOU THANKS TO THE GOVERNOR
SIGNIFICANTLY SCALED UP THE
FUNDING FOR THESE PROJECTS ARE
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF PROJECTS
UNDER WAY ACROSS THE STATE. AND
OUR PROPOSAL OF A ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS THIS YEAR. I
WILL CONTINUE THAT TYPE SO WE
CAN CONTINUE TO SCALE UP THOSE
PROJECTS. OKAY SO I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE YOU THROUGHOUT A LOT OF
NUMBERS THERE SO I AND I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE IF YOU COULD
GET ME THAT THE AMOUNT THAT'S
LEFT OVER THAT STILL NEEDS TO
BE- ALLOCATOR MOVED PROJECTS AS
AS I SAID IN MY OPENING
STATEMENT TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE. BUT IN THIS CURRENT
BUDGET THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING.
THEIR SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ALLOCATED FOR WELFARE
PREVENTION. AT TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE YES YES OKAY. BUT I HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS ON THE- ON ON
THE- ON THE ENERGY SIDE AND ON
THE- THE- THE DIESEL SALES TAX
SO I DON'T KNOW IF A WOMAN
ASKING OUR WAIT TIME TO GET TO
THE SIX HOT. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
ANYBODY THAT'S QUESTIONS FOR
SECRETARIAL CRAWFORD HAS NOT
ALTERED SO WE'LL COME BACK TO
YOU. MR FONG THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER MISTER BENNETT. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I HAVE ONE
QUESTION FOR REST SECRETARY
CROWFOOT APPRECIATE YOU. BEING
AVAILABLE FOR THIS- WE TALKED
EARLIER OF THE SUB COMMITTEE.
SOME OF OUR PREVIOUS MEETINGS
ABOUT THE NEW NORMAL- IN TERMS
OF OUR DROUGHT SITUATION AND
ARABIZATION- SITUATION- AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS- I'VE-
MENTIONED ONE OF MY COMMENTS WAS
TO MAKE SURE WE DO. PROPER
PLANNING- FOR ALL OF THE ISSUES
THAT- OR COMING FORWARD AS A
RESULT OF CLIMATE CHANGE. WE
HAVE OF FORTY FOR ME. DOLLARS
AGO OF THE REVISED HAS FORTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED
TO THE WATER BOARD. FOR DROUGHT
RESILIENCE AND WATER RIGHTS
MODERNIZATION. AND WHAT I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW WAS TO SPECIFICALLY
COVER THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
DROUGHT SECTION. AT THE WATER
BOARD. THAT SHE- HAS. DEDICATED
PERMANENT STAFF. TO BE PLANNING
FOR ADVANCED YOU'D DO ADVANCED
DROUGHT PLANNING. YEAH THANK YOU
I MAY I ASK MY COLLEAGUES CHAIR
JOAQUIN ASK ABOUT FROM THE WATER
BOARD TO RESPOND TO THAT
SPECIFIC QUESTION THANK YOU
SOMEONE MEMBER. THANK YOU.
SECRETARY AMBIGUOUS ON THE
NUMBER- THESE ARE PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND THESE POSITIONS
WOULD BE FOCUSED ON- DROUGHT
PLANNING AMONGST OTHER.
ACTIVITIES AND IT THAT WE KNOW
WE NEED TO BE DOING AND WATER
RIGHTS IN PREPARATION FOR DRY
TIMES LIKE THIS SHOULD BE VERY
MUCH A SUPPORT CONTINUATION OF
THE WORK THE BOARD IS DONE THIS
LAST YEAR. WE'RE HISTORICALLY WE
ARE- CURTAILING FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY
LOOKING AT WHAT'S HYDROLOGICALLY
AVAILABLE MATCHING THAT UP WHAT
WE UNDERSTAND. PRIORITY AREAS ON
THE WATER RIGHT SYSTEM AND
ACTUALLY ADMINISTERING THE WATER
IT'S- SO THESE ARE PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND WOULD BE FOCUSED
ON ON DRUG ACTIVITIES SO. THAT
SHOW GET SAY HERE THAT THERE PER
POSITIONS DOESN'T ACTUALLY
CREATE A DROUGHT SECTION. AND AT
THE WATER BOARD. I THE- WEATHER
OR NOT WE'RE OFFICIAL TIMELY
TIGHTLY ACROSS. I CAN GET BACK
TO YOU ON BUT KNOW THAT THE WORK
LOOK AT THE DENTIST AND PAID FOR
THEM IT'S SPECIFIC TO DROUGHT
ACTIVITIES- THEY WOULD BE HERE.
CONTINUE TO UPDATE METHODOLOGIES
EVEN IF- AND DURING WHAT TIMES-
IN. BECAUSE WE KNOW EVEN THAT
IMPORTANT WE NEED TO BE
PREPARING FOR WHEN WERE NEVER
REALLY GOING TO BE SAME TRUCK
CONDITIONS LIKE THE SECOND AND
TEN DROUGHT PLANNING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I THINK IF MEMBER.
GREAT THANK A BENNETT THE- BACK
TO UNITS FROM. SO JUST A FEW OF
FEW- ON THE MEN'S IN THE- IN
YOUR REVIEW THAT YOU HAVE- THAT
IT W. R. ND ENERGY COMMISSION
ARE- THERE'S FUNDING FOR
STRATEGIC ASSETS FOR RELY. WHAT
ARE THOSE ASSETS. SURE AM I AM
THE THREE THINK OUR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SOMEONE TO TURN TO
OUR ENERGY COMMISSION COLLEAGUES
ON THE MIND OUR D. W. R. TO GIVE
A LITTLE BIT MORE DESCRIPTION OF
WHAT'S ENTAILED IN THAT.
PROPOSAL. YES THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR THE QUESTION- THIS IS
A GOOD UP FROM CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. AND THEY JUST
PROVIDE A THAT THAT LITTLE BIT
BY. CONTEXT ON. ON WHAT RATE
BASING THIS- ASKED AND THEN KIND
OF TALK THROUGH. THE DIFFERENT-
STRATEGIES WE HAVE IN PLACE. SO
AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL- AS THE
GOVERNOR KIND OF MENTIONED IN
HIS BUDGET BRIEFING. WE ARE
ESTIMATING- THE WORST OF THE
WORST. ASPECT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT JUST MENTIONED LOOKING
AT THE LONG TERM. OVER THE NEXT
FIVE TO SIX YEARS AND
UNDERSTANDING. WHAT COULD BE A
WORST CASE SCENARIO FOR
CALIFORNIA. AND IN IN LOOKING
BACK ON TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WE REALLY HAVE COME
TO THE CONCLUSION THAT. THE
RESPONSIBILITY. OFF OF YOU KNOW
GETTING THE ENERGY TO. AND
KEEPING THE LIGHTS ON. IS
BECOMING INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT
TO PULL CAL BUT THE TOOLS WE
HAVE IN HAND. CLIMATE CHANGE AND
DO. CABINETS FIRE AND HEAT IS
READY TO COULD. SO CAN I JUST
GET I LIKE THAT A GOOD ACTORS I
DO. INNER BY DOING A- INTO THAT
WHAT ARE THE ASSETS. YEAH I
STOOD THERE ARE. BROADLY AT.
THREE STRATEGIES THAT THE DEVICE
HAS. SAID IN A TALK TO ONE BY
ONE SO THE FIRST ONE IS THAT THE
W. R. IT'S ABOUT FOUR FOUR POINT
TWO BILLION UP FORTY W. R. APPLE
. STRATEGIC RESERVE AT SWITCHING
. BROADLY THINGS- ONE TO KEEP.
OUR THOSE RESOURCE THAT ARE
CRITICAL FOR TYERMAN THAT COULD
BE HELD ON. IN THIS OUT OF MY-
INSURANCE. ARE A SECOND PART OF
THE STRATEGIC ASSETS WOULD
INCLUDE. BUILDING ARE BRINGING
IN MORE SKILLED IN THE GROUND-
SIMILAR TO. WHAT THE IDEA OF
YOUR HAVE DONE PREVIOUSLY BUT
IT'S BEEN PRETTY- BEST GENSETS
OR- OUT OF MARKET. AFTER CLEAN
ENERGY AT PEOPLE THIRTEEN THAT
SO THERE ARE TWO BUCKETS THERE.
FOR CC- WE HAVE ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION. IN IN
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE WHAT.
DISTRIBUTED ACTIVITY BACKUPS-
BUT OFFICERS WELL AS I SAID
APPLE. TO THE DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
BACK ABOUT THAT INCLUDES THREE
COMPONENTS. SO ONE WOULD BE. ALL
THREE ARE ARE AIMED AT- THEY- ON
BACK OF GENERATION IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S AVAILABLE
WHICH IS ABOUT FOURTEEN THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS. TO DEPEND ON THEM
GETTING GETTING EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS SO THE FIRST ONE OF
THAT WOULD BE. PROVIDING A
MEDICATION EQUIPMENT CLICK I SEE
ARE STILL PUT ON EXISTING-
GENSETS THAT COULD BE AVAILABLE
BY DOING EMERGENCIES AT TWO IT
STARTED TO. FUNDING SO PROVIDING
INCENTIVES FOR EARLY PLACEMENT
OF. A POSSIBLE- BACK GENERATORS
BUT BRINGING THEM INTO A CLEAN
PORTFOLIO BUT ALSO FUNDING NEW
BACK OF GENERATIONS THAT ARE
CLEAN. AT FACILITIES THAT ARE
STRATEGIC AND NEED. AND THE
SECOND ELEMENT OF THAT WOULD BE
ON THE SUPPLY SIDE- PUTTING. IN
ADDITIONAL GENERATION CLEAN
GENERATION EXISTING FACILITIES
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN ABILITY
OPPORTUNITY. BUT ALSO INCREASING
THE OVERALL. EFFICIENCY OF THE
EXISTING THERMAL. POWER AND TO
THINK OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE. AND
THE ELEMENT THANKS FOR DEMAND
FOR SUPPORT. WHICH OF THE
PROVIDE INTENT FOR LARGE SCALE-
LOADED UP DOES THE P. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT. IN IN
IN TERMS OF THE DIESELS TEXAS-
IF YOU'RE GOING TO SPEND THE
SALE TAX OF DIESEL IS
DEPARTMENT. YOU CAN ASSIST THE
STATE'S OF THE DIESEL SELL
THAT'S WHY DO THE SUSPENSION FOR
AND GASOLINE. ARM SO JACOB KERN
A FIVE- THE WE DECIDED GO WITH
THE D. SALES. I'M FOR NOT THREE
THE FIRST ONE THAT. THE STATE
ACTUALLY DOESN'T APPLY A-
GENERAL FUND TAX RATE ON THE
SALE OF GAS. THERE ARE OTHER
SALES TAX RATES THAT APPLY TO
GASOLINE SALES BY DUSTIN FOR THE
LOCALS AND SO WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE THE SAME AMOUNT
OF CONTROL OVER- GAS TAX
REVENUES FOR GENERAL FUND
PURPOSES. AS WE DO PRODUCE OR
AVENUES. YEAH OTHER PART OF THE-
OKAY WAS BAD. THAT GAP OUR BUT
HISTORICAL DIESEL AND GASOLINE
PRICE RIGHT NOW IS EXTREMELY
HIGH AND THAT'S BECAUSE WE HAVE
A LOT OF COUNTRIES THAT USE
DIESEL FOR A HIGHER PROPORTION
OF THEIR VEHICLES I'M NOT GOING
THROUGH A BIT OF A SUPPLY CRUNCH
RIGHT NOW AND SO THE GAP BETWEEN
GAYS ALL AND- GASOLINE PRICES
HAS GROWN TO HISTORICALLY HIGH
LEVELS. WE THOUGHT DIESEL NEEDED
SOME EXTRA ATTENTION. SPECIALLY
GIVEN THE DIRECT IMPACT DIESEL
CAN HAVE ALL AND I'M GONNA TO
INFLATION BECAUSE DIESELS
OBVIOUSLY TO TRANSPORT A LOT OF
FRIENDS AROUND- AND SURVEYS THAT
IS A BIG CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
PRICE OF- CONSUMER GUIDES TO SO
THAT'S THE PERFECT SEGUE TO MY
OBVIOUS QUESTION WHICH IS IF YOU
BACK FAILED. THE SALES TAX- THE
DID THE DEAL DIESEL SALES TAX
SUSPENSION AND THE FACT THAT
GASOLINE ALSO NEEDS TO BE THE
PRICE REDUCTION BECAUSE YOUR
KNOWLEDGE THEY'RE GOING UP WHY
NOT BACK FILL INS IS THE PLACE
TO SPEND THE GAS TAX. THE
STATE'S GAS TAX- RIGHT NOW WE
RETRACTED- ON OUR DOUBTS
PROPOSAL TO A GAS TAX REBATE
THAT'S INTENDED TO. PROVIDE THE
RELIEF FOR. CALIFORNIA DRIVERS
MAKING DOUBTS ABOUT OUR AND MORE
TARGETED WAY I'M- PROVIDING THAT
REALLY WITHOUT- CRICKETING
COMPLICATED BUDGET MECHANISMS
AFTER THE FACT- OKAY YOU SEE THE
IRONY THAT YOU BACK FILLED THE
SUSPENSION OF THE DIESEL SALES
TAX BECAUSE YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PRICE OF DIESEL BOND
PRODUCTS INFLATION BUT THEN YOU
DON'T USE THE SAME LOGIC FOR
GASOLINE WHICH MORE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY USE- TO THE STATE. AND
THE L. L. ACTUALLY SAYS THAT
REDUCING THE FUEL TAXES WILL
MOST DIRECTLY TARGET- THOSE
AFFECTED BY HIGH GAS PRICES
BECAUSE IT'S LINKED TO THE
AMOUNT OF CONSUMPTION SO I KNOW
THAT'S A RHETORICAL QUESTION BUT
I JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THAT IRONY THANK YOU PROJECT.
THANK YOU MR FONG. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS MISTER BENNETT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF THIS IS SAID
ABOUT THE SELF GENERATION
INCENTIVE PROGRAM- ONE BILLION
TO FUND SOLAR AND- AND STORAGE
THE PROGRAM IS BRITISH
SIGNIFICANTLY OVERSUBSCRIBED AND
SO MIKE IS HOW DO WE ARE AT ONE
DOLLAR AMOUNT. WHEN SO
SUBSCRIBED AND DUBBED THE MIGHT
ADD YOU KNOW IT SEEMS THAT WITH
THE WITH THE POTENTIAL GRID
PROBLEMS WE HAVE COMING UP AGAIN
I POINT OUT IT'S SAID THAT THE
PROBLEM THAT COULD BE ADDRESSED
WITH STORAGE IT'S THE PEAK OUR
PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE- AND NOT
THE OTHER AND- SO VISIT SEEMS AT
HOME STORAGE- HOME SOLAR WITH
STORAGE COULD BE AWAY
PARTICULARLY IF WE INCENTIVIZE
WHATEVER FUNDING WE WERE DOING
IF WE TIED THAT TO. PEOPLE WHO A
INSTALL STORAGE HELPING AT THAT
PEAK HOUR TIME PERIOD WITH THEIR
STORAGE THAT SEEMS LIKE A REALLY
HELP US- THE PROBLEM AND- NOT
HAVE TO KEEP THE AS MUCH- OTHER-
OF FOSSIL FUEL THE- BACKUP
GENERATION AND- AVAILABLE. SO
COULD YOU HELP ME WITH THE HOW
DID WE END UP WITH A ONE DOLLAR
PLEASE SURE I WOULD POINT TO
JUST BUT YOU KNOW THE OVERALL
ENERGY PACKAGE AND THERE'S A
NUMBER OF COMPONENTS. THAT WE
TRY TO ADDRESS AS PART OF THE
BROAD ENERGY STRUCTURE AND IT
ALSO POINT OUT THAT THIS EIGHT
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
ADDITION TO THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS ALSO PROPOSED A
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. DOESN'T REAL
SIZEABLE INVESTMENT AND- THERE
ARE AGAIN AND OF PRIORITIES IN
THIS A- AND PICKING AND CHOOSING
WHAT AREAS TO FOR. ON AND
AMOUNTED TO PART OF THE- OVERALL
THROUGH. HI TO TAKE BACK THE
COMMENTS OF THE INTEREST IN S.
S. CHIP. PROGRAMS BUT- AND THEN
THE INTEREST IS ADAM- ON SOLAR
STORE. AT THIS. SO HAPPY TAKE
PICTURES NOT FACT RICHER
PARTICULARLY IN THE SHORT RUN I
MEAN WE ARE WE THINK WE HAVE A
SHORT RUN PROBLEM AND YOU. YOU
MAY FIND PEOPLE BE WILLING TO-
YOU KNOW FOR A TWO YEAR PERIOD-
FOR ASSISTANCE- FOR TO GET THE
CREDIT- MAYBE WILL TO. USE THEIR
STORAGE TO HELP WITH THE- PEAK
HOUR CRUNCH THAT WE HAVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- AND THEN- THAT. I
THINK ALL. OF PLEASE MAKE. AT
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU S. M. MEMBER IF THERE ARE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS THEN WE WILL
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT. WILL BE
EXPECTING AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE HEARING
AND ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THAT
NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957 PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. EACH OF
YOU WILL HAVE ONE MINUTE TO
SPEAK UP TO ONE MINUTE. IS THERE
I THINK I CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
IN THE HEARING ROOM HADN'T-
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ALL I DO IS LOOK UP. IT
MANNING WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF OF CATALINA CHANNEL
EXPRESS AND- IF IT COUNTS
AGAINST MY TIME SO BE IT BUT I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU- ANALYSIS.
WHEN YOUR LAST HEARING SPEND THE
LAST PUBLIC HEARING AND- IT'S
BEEN A PLEASURE WORKING WITH YOU
AND- THE WAIVER AND THE HEARING
IS BEEN EVERY HEARING HERE AND-
ALL THE MEETINGS AND
INTERACTIONS YOU'VE BEEN. VERY
THOUGHTFUL AND- PATIENT AND-
IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE THANK YOU
SAM THANK YOU MOM ON BEHALF OF
CATALINA CHANNEL EXPRESS- OUT
THERE A PRIVATE COMPANY THAT
RUNS THE LIFELINE TO CATALINA
ISLAND WHICH IS THE FERRIES THAT
GO BACK AND FORTH EVERYDAY. THE
REASON WE'RE HERE AND YOU HAVE A
BUDGET AUGMENTATION REQUEST FOR
COURT STAFF ON THIS ISSUE IS A
HARBOR CRAFT REGULATION THAT WAS
PASSED THIS YEAR. WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH CARBON THIS ISSUE-
AND- UNFORTUNATELY TO MEET THE
TIER FOR AIR QUALITY STANDARDS
WHICH GET GREENHOUSE GAS
BENEFITS AND EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. IT'S NOT AS THEY
HAVE- PROGRAM BECAUSE THERE IS
NO GREEN HYDROGEN OR ELECTRIC
FOR AN OCEAN GOING VESSEL YET ON
WE WILL NEED TO REPLACE ALL OF
OUR VESSELS AT TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. PER FERRY FOR A HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION- WE WOULD REQUEST
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET BECAUSE A PRIVATE COMPANY
CANNOT FINANCE THE ON OWN AND OR
READ IN THE FAIR ABOUT SOME
POSSIBLE AND SO- WE WOULD LIKE A
PATH TOWARDS COMPLIANCE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH CARP. AND IT
WOULD BE- THERE A COMMON CARRIER
REGULATED BY THE PEAS. AND IF WE
CAN GET SOME MATCHING FUNDS- IT
IT WOULD BE HUGELY HELPFUL
OTHERWISE THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO GET THEIR- LASTLY THERE
IS NO CAR MORE IN FUNDING
AVAILABLE SO WE REALLY NEED TO
FIND A POT OF FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR. THAT COULD BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO THEM TO HELP
FINANCE. THESE NEW FERRY
PURCHASE S. THANK YOU MISS CHAIR
. THANK GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
BURSTS AND STAFF RECALL MONSTER
TONIGHT WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND I TO WANT TO THANK
YOU MISTER BLOOM- FOR ALL YOU'VE
ACCOMPLISHED HERE AND- STAFF
OVER THE YEARS I KNOW HOW DEEPLY
PERSONAL THESE ISSUES ARE TO YOU
IT SHOWS THROUGH ALL FOR ALL THE
HALF A DOZEN YEARS YOU'VE BEEN
HERE AND I YOU'RE ALSO A REALLY
DECENT HUMAN BEING SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT SOME. ARE I AM
HERE TO- ADVOCATE TO RESTORE
FUNDING TO THE STATE WIDE PARK A
COMMUNITY REVITALIZATION PROGRAM
WHICH IS OUT OF MONEY IT'S THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL GRANT PROGRAM
OPINION THAT THE STATE RUNS THE
WAY THAT THE- RUN THAT PROGRAM
AND REALLY DO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO GO ALONG WITH IT
IT SPENDS OVERSUBSCRIBED BY
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS OF THERE'S
NOT A SINGLE MEMBER. FUNDED IN
THEIR DISTRICT AND IF YOU ARE
PARK POOR YOU ARE VULNERABLE
PARK PORT EANS LOW INCOME
THERE'S A 100% CORRELATION IF WE
WANT TO PROTECT VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE TO START
WHERE THEY LIVE AND PARKS ARE
MULTI BENEFITS RECREATION IT'S
MENTAL EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH IT'S A HEAT MITIGATION
IT'S BEEN PROVED AIR AND WATER
QUALITY I KNOW WHAT I'M SPEAKING
TO THE CHOIR HERE BUT IT'S OUT
OF FUNDING AND ANA IT'S THE BEST
INVESTMENT ORDER AT LEAST THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE. ANA
INVESTMENT YOU CAN MAKE TO CHECK
ALL THE BOXES THAT WE ALL CARE
ABOUT THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME'S TOM KNOX
WITHOUT A CLEANER NOW WE MANAGED
TO CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM IN
SILICON VALLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
VALLEY AIR DISTRICT- WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PROPOSED
FUNDING SPLIT BETWEEN THE FIVE
DISTRICTS CURRENTLY OFFERING
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL AND THE
PROPOSED NEW STATEWIDE PROGRAM
FROM CARP. IT MAY SEEM SENSIBLE
TO COMBINE THESE PROGRAMS
STREAMLINED THEM AND OFFER ONE
STATEWIDE- SOLUTION HOWEVER EACH
OF CARBS SEVEN SENTENCE ARE
UNIQUE THEY SERVE A UNIQUE
AUDIENCE- AND WITH THE EQUITY
PROGRAMS AIM TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IS REALLY IMPORTANT
THESE BE MANAGED VERY CLOSE TO
THE GROUND NEAR THE COMMUNITIES
THEY SERVE- IF THE CURRENT
FUNDING PROPOSAL IN MAY REVISE
IS ENACTED THE TEN MILLION
ALLOCATED TO SILICON VALLEY WILL
NOT BE SUFFICIENT TO EVEN FIND.
THE EXISTING CUSTOMERS IN OUR
PIPELINE WITH APPLICATIONS
PENDING. UP ONCE WE SERVE THOSE
EXISTING CUSTOMERS WOULD BE
FORCED TO SHUT DOWN OUR PROGRAM
AS EARLY AS THIS DECEMBER- WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT- THIS
COMMITTEE I CONSIDER. SHIFTING
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
ALLOCATED TO THE STATEWIDE
PROGRAM BACK TO THE FIVE
DISTRICTS- AND- PUT THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE FIVE
DISTRICTS OVER THE STATEWIDE
PROGRAM- THIS WILL THEN COVER
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT. OF THE
POPULATION THE STATE 90% OF THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BETH- ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THREE DIFFERENT
CLIENTS TODAY- FIRST WATER REEFS
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WATER
RECYCLERS. VERY EXCITED TO SEE A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
RECYCLED WATER- IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET BUT
AS YOU KNOW THAT IS. ERELI EVEN
A DROP MAYBE IT THE LITTLE.
PIECE OF MIST- IN THE NEED FOR
RECYCLED WATER IN THE STATE
THERE'S A- TEN TO TWELVE BILLION
DOLLAR NEED IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS FOR RECYCLED WATER. AND WE
JUST THINK NOW IS THE TIME TO
INVEST IN CREATING NEW WATER
SUPPLIES AMMAR AGENCIES ARE
DOING A GREAT JOB OF CONSERVING
BUT CREATING NEW WATER SUPPLIES.
TO REDUCE RELIANCE ON IMPORTED
WATER- CAN ONLY COME FROM
RECYCLED WATER SO WE ENCOURAGE
ENCOURAGE AN INCREASE INVESTMENT
FOR. RECYCLED WTER TO THE STATE
BOARD. SECOND ON BEHALF OF THE
THEY ARE ONE OF THE WORST UP
GRANT- OF AWARDEES IN THE WATER
STORAGE INVESTMENT PROGRAM THE
CHINO BASIN. PROGRAM IS A VERY
COOL- PROGRAM THAT- ARE YOU WAY
FOR GOES WATER- FROM LAKE
ORVILLE AND CREATES THEIR OWN
WATER STORAGE PROGRAM DOWN IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE- BY CLEANING
UP GROUNDWATER SO VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF ANYTHING. WE CAN
DO TO GET MORE FUNDING- FOR THE
INCREASED COSTS THAT THOSE WITH
THE PROJECTS ARE FACING WHEN
WENT IN WOODEN COURAGE THE BODY
TO. ACCELERATE THAT FUNDING
BEYOND THE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY TWENTY SIX BUDGET YEAR.
AND THEN FINALLY FOR THE AND
ASKING ME FOR THE AGRICULTURAL
ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION- AT
THE P. YOU SEE PROPOSAL- THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT ON ON- AS-
MOVING TO- I'M LOOKING I'M SORRY
NOT A VOLUMETRIC RATES BUT- THE
- BASIC RATES I THINK I'M
GETTING THE NOD AND I'M BLANKING
A HUMP BUT CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
THAT IS ACTUALLY GOING TO WORK-
IF YOU DO A FIXED CHARGE. IF YOU
DO A FIXED CHARGE WHERE DOES
THAT COME FROM WHEN YOU HAVE I
USE THAT HAVE- REVENUE
REQUIREMENTS ARE W JUST GONNA
BE MOVING IT FROM RESIDENTIAL
TO. TWO OTHER CUSTOMER CLASSES
SAY THE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY
OR WE CAN REDUCING THE OVERALL
REVENUE REQUIREMENT SO AS WE SEE
THE DETAILS WE'D LIKE YOU TO ASK
THOSE QUESTIONS BECAUSE I KNOW
WE DON'T HAVE THOSE ANSWERS
RIGHT NOW- BUT APPRECIATE THOSE
CONSIDERATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR ALSO PROVING
HOW MUCH YOU CAN COMMUNICATE
WITH JUST I CUT TO. J. BOWMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
ALLEN ABS WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. THE
MAY REVISE ADDS TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE AB SIX SEVENTEEN
PROGRAM FOR INCENTIVES TO BRING
THE TOTAL TO TWO HUNDRED
MILLION. WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
INCREASE AND NOTE THAT THE L. A.
O. RECENTLY IDENTIFIED SIX
SEVENTEEN INCENTIVES. IS ONE OF
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS
TO REDUCE AIR POLLUTION. THE
TOTAL AMOUNT IS STILL 23% LESS
THAN LAST YEAR'S AMOUNT. IN
ADDITION THE MAY REVISE LEFT THE
SIX SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION
PORTION IT FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH IS THE SAME AMOUNT IS FOUR
YEARS AGO WHEN THEY WERE SEVEN
LESS COMMUNITIES. TO SERVE
THROUGH THE STATE MANDATED
PROGRAM. THE MAY REVISE ALSO
PROPOSES TO ACCELERATE FUNDING
TO THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAM. WITH ONLY FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS GOING TO THE FIVE
LARGEST AIR DISTRICTS CURRENTLY
RUNNING CC FOR A PROGRAMS. AND
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS GOING TO CREATE A NEW
PARALLEL PROGRAM. INCLUDING NEW
PROGRAMS IN REGIONS CURRENTLY
SERVED BY THOSE THEIR DISTRICTS.
INSTEAD MORE FUNDING SHOULD BE
ALLOCATED TO DISTRICTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY OVER SUBSCRIBED IN
RUNNING THESE SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL TURNER ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY AND ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE OVER THE YEARS
TO HELP SUPPORT THE TRANSIT
NEEDS IN L. A. COUNTY IT'S VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED- WITH A GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY BEFORE US WITH THE
SURPLUS TO INVEST IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND I'D
LIKE TO LEAVE YOU WITH THREE KEY
THOUGHTS THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES
TO INVEST IN OUR TRANSIT SYSTEM
WE ARE NUMBER RAIL PROJECTS
AROUND THE STATE. THAT COULD
BENEFIT FROM IT AN INFUSION OF
FUNDS WE HAVE THREE PROJECTS IN
THE FEDERAL PIPELINE THAT COULD
BENEFIT SUCH AS WHAT'S WHAT'S
SANTANA THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
PROJECT IN INGLEWOOD TRANSIT
QUARTER THOSE ARE SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEVERAGE
FEDERAL FUNDS AND I WOULD NOTE
THAT IF YOU IF WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSED ON LEVERAGING FEDERAL
FUNDS WE SHOULD ALSO THINK ABOUT
ONE OF THE LARGEST TRANSIT
PROJECTS IN THE COUNTRY THAT'S
COMING UP THE SUPPOSED TO
TRANSIT CORRIDOR THAT PROJECT
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO LEVERAGE
PROBABLY MORE FEDERAL FUNDS IN
CALIFORNIA THAN HAS EVER BEEN
LEVERAGED FOR A TRANSPORTATION
PROJECT. AT THE SAME TIME THERE
ARE ALSO KEY TRANSIT PROJECTS
THAT ARE ADVANCING WITHOUT
FEDERAL FUNDS SUCH AS THE
FOOTHILL EXTENSION THE GOAL LINE
HE SAID EXTENSION OF THE GOAL
LINE AND THE EXTENSION OF THE
GREEN LINE INTO THE SOUTH BAY
ALL OF THOSE PROJECTS THOSE LAST
THREE ARE MOVING WITHOUT FEDERAL
FUNDS BUT THEY ALSO HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO CREATE SIGNIFICANT
BENEFITS IN L. A. OUNTY. THE
SECOND AREA I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON
IS YOU'VE HEARD IS ASKED FOR
FUNDING FOR THE OLYMPICS AND I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT SAID
ABOUT IT BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT IT IS MUCH MORE THAN
THE OLYMPICS- WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THE OLYMPICS IN TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT BUT BETWEEN NOW AND THEN
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF EVENTS IN
BETWEEN WE JUST HOPE IT HOSTED
THE SUPERBOWL WE HAVE THE ALL
STAR GAME COMING UP THIS SUMMER
IS GOING TO BE A COLLEGE
FOOTBALL NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP.
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE GOING TO
HAVE THE U. S. OPEN CHAMPIONSHIP
WRESTLEMANIA THE NCAA DIVISION
ONE- ROOM WESTRIDGE IN
CHAMPIONSHIP. IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR POTENTIALLY THE WORLD CUP
IN TWENTY TWENTY- YOU YOU YOU
HAD ME AT WRESTLEMANIA. I WAS
ALMOST THERE WE MAYBE THE BTS
CONCERT- AND THEN UP NOT TO
MENTION THE SUMMER OLYMPICS AND
PARALYMPICS IN TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT THE WORLD IS COMING TO LA
IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE
OLYMPICS. AND IF THAT'S DOUBLE
DIPPING I'D BE HAPPY TO TALK TO
ANY OTHER REASON THAT HAS EVENTS
LIKE THAT LASTLY I JUST WANT TO
MENTION THE OPPORTUNITIES TO
INVEST IN COMMUTER RAIL AND ARE
COMMUTER INTERCITY RAIL PROGRAMS
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT THINGS
THAT CAN BE DONE TO CONNECT THE
ANALYST ALY LINE. IN PROJECTS
AND SAND SAN DIEGO AS WELL AS
CONNECTING THE BAY AREA TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO. THE WITH THAT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS ERICA ROMERO ON BEHALF
OF THE NRDC ACTION FUND IT WE
JUST LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
FOR FOUR ITEMS IN THE INCLUDING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET.
THIRTY THREE MILLION FOR THE
PHARMA SCHOOL PROGRAM EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION. FOR THE HEALTHY
SOILS PROGRAM A HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION FOR THE SENATE WATER
EFFICIENCY ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM.
AND FIFTEEN MILLION FOR THE
POLLINATOR HABITAT PROGRAM. WE
REQUEST THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORT
FOR FIFTEEN MILLION. TO COVER
THREE YEARS OF FUNDING FOR NEW
ORGANIC TRANSITION PROGRAM AND A
HUNDRED MILLION. IN FUNDING OVER
TWO YEARS TO EXPAND OUR STATE'S
CLIMATE FRIENDLY. HEALTHY FOOD
ACCESS INFRASTRUCTURE BOTH ARE
MEMBER SUPPORTED ASKS. WE ALSO
SUPPORT AND APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAY REVISION
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR ITS
INVESTMENT INTO THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD. DEPARTMENT
EFFICIENT WILDLIFE STATE PARKS
AND STATE CONSERVANCIES. AS WELL
AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION AFFORDED. FURTHER
THIRTY BY THIRTY GOALS- WE
SUPPORT THIS ADMINISTRATION'S A
HUNDRED MILLION TO SUPPORT
TRIBAL PARTNERSHIPS HOWEVER WE
URGE. THAT THE FINAL BUDGET
INCLUDES SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT THE SENATE HAS PROPOSED IN
ITS CLIMATE BUDGET. INCLUDING AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THIRTY BY THIRTY. AND THREE
BILLION FOR COASTAL RESILIENCE.
THE SENATE'S PROPOSAL BETTER
NEEDED TO ACHIEVE CALIFORNIA'S
THIRTY BY THIRTY AND CLIMATE
RESILIENT SCHOOLS. AND LASTLY
NRDC ACTION FUND SUPPORTS THE
FORTY MILLION. DOLLARS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL FOR
REDUCING EMISSIONS FROM H. FC'S
AND WE ASK THAT YOU ENSURE THAT
THE STATE BUILDING CODE.
STANDARDS ARE UPDATED TO
ACCOMMODATE THIS HFC TRANSITION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS I'M
ASK EVERYBODY TO TRY TO BETTER
ADHERE TO THE ONE MINUTE TIME
LIMIT WE HAVE FIFTY PEOPLE- AND
I'M SURE THAT NUMBER'S GOING TO
GROW WHO ARE. WAITING ON A TO
SPEAK ON THE TELEPHONE SO. THANK
YOU VENTURA- A GOOD MORNING
CHAPLAIN MEMBERS- STEVEN MYERS
ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- THE COURTS ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FIFTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE TO THE-
CCC THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS FOR EXPANDING- EDUCATION
AND ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES. AT
LOCAL AND TRIBAL COURSE FOR
CLIMATE LEADERSHIP. THIS FUNDING
WILL EMPOWER YOUNG ADULTS FROM-SOME OF THE MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE. TO
ENGAGE IN PROJECTS THAT WILL
CREATE MORE CLIMATE RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES AND TRAIN THEM TO BE
THE STATE'S NEXT GENERATION OF
CLIMATE LEADERS. AND WE ALSO ARE
ENCOURAGED BY THE ADDITIONAL
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE MAY REVISED TO EXPAND
FUNDING FOR THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM- IN LIGHT
OF THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE
WOULD ASK THE SENATE EXCUSE ME
FOR THE ASSEMBLY TO CONSIDER
SENATOR GONZALEZ'S REQUEST. TO
ALLOCATE. TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
OF THAT NOW ONE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLAR POT OF FUNDING- TO THE
CCC AND THE LOCAL COURTS TO
ALLOW OUR CORPS MEMBERS TO
CONTINUE ENGAGING IN PROJECTS.
THAT MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES MORE
WALKABLE AND BIKEABLE AND WILL
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY AND REDUCE
VEHICLE EMISSIONS BY REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
KYLE JONES WITH COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER- FOR THE MAY REVISE WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR DROUGHT INCLUDING
POSITIONS AT THE WATER BOARD AS
WELL AS POSITIONS ON THE WATER
BOARD TO SUPPORT S. R. F.
IMPLEMENTATION FROM THE
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE LAW WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE REQUEST FOR
FUNDS FOR ALLENSWORTH STATE
PARK- UNAFFORDABILITY WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF MOVING TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO BUY
WHAT PROGRAM AT CST TO HELP WITH
CRISIS ASSISTANCE BUT NOT THAT
THAT FUNDING IS NOT AVAILABLE
FOR FULLY UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES
AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE REQUESTED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FROM THE
STATE TO SUPPORT THOSE FAMILIES
IT FOR VOTERS INSTANCE. WE ALSO
WANT TO KNOW THAT THERE'S NO
FUNDING IN THE MAY REVISE FOR
LONG TERM WATER RATE ASSISTANCE
AND WE BELIEVE IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT THE STATE THIS YEAR-
PROVIDE THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
TO HELP PEOPLE PAY THEIR WATER
BILLS GOING FORWARD TO PREVENT
THE NEED FOR CRISIS ASSISTANCE-
IN THE FIRST PLACE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. STEAMED IN A
BENEVOLENCE CHAIRMAN DILUTION
HERE- ON BEHALF OF THE FORTY
CONSERVATION LEAGUE THE STATE'S
ONLY A BLACK WOULD LAND
CONSERVANCY- WANT TO TESTIFY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF MANY OF THE
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE BEING MADE
INTO THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD- I WOULD SAY A WEEK WE DO
APPRECIATE THE SENATE- PACKAGE
IN THEIR AGGRESSIVENESS
CONCERNING- CLIMATE ACTION AND
RESILIENCE- BUT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE ASSEMBLY ON
THAT AS WELL. I THINK WE'RE A
LITTLE DISAPPOINTED CONCERNING
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
THAT THERE ARE NOT. A MORE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT INTO THE
PUBLIC ACCESS PROGRAMS WE'RE
VERY STRONG BELIEVERS AGAIN AND
CONSERVATION BUT CONSERVATION
WITH THE PUBLIC ACCESS
COMPONENT. AND SO WE ARE ASK YOU
ALL TO CONSIDER DOUBLING DOWN
AND CREATING SUFFICIENT
STATUTORY AUTHORITY. FOR THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD TO.
ART WHEN IT THINKS FEASIBLE
UTILIZE OTHER PROGRAM DOLLARS TO
COVER PROJECTS THAT- ALSO
INCLUDES TRONG PUBLIC ACCESS
COMPONENT I ALSO WANT TO SAY
THAT WHEN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
ONE HUNDRE MILLION DOLLARS SET
ASIDE FOR TRIBES THOUGH. FRANKLY
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT SHOULD- BE
A BIT BROADER THAN TRIBES- AND
PROBABLY POSSIBLY INCLUDE UP BY
CUT BY PA COMMUNITIES AT LARGE-
AND SO WOULD LOVE TO COMMUNICATE
WITH YOU ALL ON THAT FURTHER
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS REBEKAH MARKETS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN FARMLAND
TRUST CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK CARBON CYCLE
INSTITUTE AND THE CALIFORNIA
CERTIFIED ORGANIC FARMERS. FIRST
I WANT TO EXPRESS OUR DEEP
APPRECIATION TO BOTH GOVERNOR
NEWSOM AND THE ASSEMBLY TO THEIR
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING CLIMATE
CHANGE THAT BEING SAID WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ME REVISED DOES
NOT INCLUDE MORE INVESTMENTS IN
THE WORKING LAND SECTOR. FARMERS
AND RANCHERS WANT TO BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION BUT WE NEED
INCENTIVES AND RESOURCES TO DO
SO. SPECIFICALLY WE WANT FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR AGRICULTURAL LAND
CONSERVATION AND LAND ACCESS
CROPLANDS ARE MISSING FROM THE
LAND TYPES WITH WHICH CAN ACCESS
CONSERVATION DOLLARS IN THE
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS VCPE. ROB
PLANS ARE WE URGE YOU TO FIND
THE CALIFORNIA FARMLAND
CONSERVATION PROGRAM OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD LIKE
INVESTMENTS TO THE ALTERNATIVE
MANURE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
PRESCRIBED GRAZING
INFRASTRUCTURE ABOUT A
COMPREHENSIVE AGREEMENT COULD
TRANSITION PROGRAM WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND SET ASIDE FOR
PROGRAM EVALUATION OF THE
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE
PROGRAMS. AT CDFA WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE OUR
CONTINUING OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MICHAEL CHAIRED ON BEHALF OF THE
CAN- COMMITTEE ALLIANCE WITH
FAMILY FARMERS CASF REPRESENTS
OVER EIGHT THOUSAND SMALL AND
MID SCALE FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA
AND HAS WORKED FOR OVER FORTY
YEARS. TO PRESERVE FAMILY SCALE
AGRICULTURE AND PROMOTE
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE CDFA IS CALIFORNIA
UNDERSERVED AND SMALL PRODUCERS
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE DROUGHT
FINANCIAL RELIEF AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY EQUIPMENT UPGRADES-
AS PART OF THE SIGMA
IMPLEMENTATION- PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION WE STRONGLY
RECOMMEND YOU CONSIDER ADDING
TEN MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
ESSENTIAL OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT TO SMALL SCALE AND
UNDERSERVED FAMILY FARMERS ARE
SMALL SCALE FARMERS. FACE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS. TO
ENGAGING WITH THEIR GSA'S- AND
THEY NEED THESE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROCESS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT OVER THE
PHONE OPERATOR ARE YOU READY FOR
US. YES MISTER CHAIR WE READY
GREAT I UNDERSTAND YOU'VE GOT-
QUITE A FEW PEOPLE WAITING SO
LET'S GET TO IT. AGAIN ARE
SPEAKING LIMITS- A TIME LIMITS
ARE ONE MINUTE PLEASE. AS A
REMINDER IF USED IF YOU HAVE NOT
PRESSED ONE THEN ZERO TO SIGNAL
THAT YOU WISH TO COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME DO
NOT PRESS ONE ZERO SECOND TIME
IS THIS WILL REMOVE YOU FROM THE
KILL. GOING TO GO TO LINE HAND.
WHY TENURE WHILE OPEN GOOD
MORNING- THIS IS LEGAL KEEP FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY- I'M GOING TO ECHO
SUPPORT FOR THE NAY REVISED
INVESTMENT IN WC BEING SPECIAL
WILDLIFE PARK'S CONSERVANCY
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION WHAT
THE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR TRIBAL PARTNERSHIPS-
I ALSO WANT TO ECHO SUPPORT FOR
THE SENATE PROPOSED ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT THIRTY BY
THIRTY AND CLIMATE RESILIENT
SPECIFICALLY THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION A THIRTY BY THIRTY THREE
BILLION FOR COASTAL RESILIENCE
AND AN ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED
MILLION A YEAR TO SUPPORT
CAPACITY BUILDING FOR
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING ON THE
GROUND EMPLOYMENT THIRTY BY
THIRTY. PARTICULARLY INCREDIBLE
NUMBER COMMUNITIES- AS PART OF
INVESTMENTS WE DEFINITELY URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER A
50% INVESTMENT SATISFIED FOR
BIODIVERSITY CONSERVATION
ACTIONS FOCUSED ON THE. CLIENT
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. AND
ALLOW AS DATA PLAN SOCIETY. WITH
STRONG- THE THAT THE FINAL
BUDET INCLUDES A KEY TIME HAD
CAN BEST A MILLION TO COMPLETE
THE STATE FINDS CAL VEGETATION
MAPPING WE'VE GOT 40% LEFT TO
DO- IN SOME OF OUR MOST CLIMATE
VULNERABLE AREAS- AND THIS WILL
PROVIDE CRITICAL DATA AS TO
WHERE THE MOST IMPORTANT AREAS
ARE FOR BIODIVERSITY PROTECTION.
AND INFORM ONGOING DECISIONS
THAT WE NEED TO SUPPORT THE
CLIMATE RESILIENT THANKS SO MUCH
FOR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT OUR NEXT OUR NEXT WILL BE
LINE TWENTY EIGHT. HELLO
JEROBOAM IN MEMBERSMINDS DALY
CITY BOY A PUBLIC POLICY
COORDINATOR WITH MY HOBBY
DEFINITELY AND TRACKS WE'RE
NONPROFIT FIVE OH ONE SEE THREE
DESERT CONSERVATION ORGANIZATION
HEADQUARTERED IN JOSHUA TREE. WE
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE
MINISTRATIONS MADE BUDGET
REVISIONS FOR ITS INVESTMENT
INTO THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD DEPARTMENT OF SYSTEM
WILDLIFE AND STATE CONSERVANCIES
TO FURTHER THIRTY BY THIRTY AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AS FOLLOWS
FUNDING FOR TRIBAL ENGAGEMENT.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE REQUESTING
THAT THE FINAL BUDGET REFLECT
THE SENATE'S BUDGET PROPOSAL IN
ITS CLIMATE BUDGET AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION SO WE'RE
BETTER SITUATED TO ACHIEVE THE
LAUDABLE GOALS FROM THIRTY BY
THIRTY WE ALSO URGING ADDITIONAL
BUDGET LINE OF ONE HUNDRED
MILLION SPECIFICALLY TO SUPPORT
CAPACITY BUILDING FOR
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS OURS. AS
WE ENGAGE ON THIRTY BY THIRTY
BURKE THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AS WE WORK JUST TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S INVIOLABLE. DESERT
ECOSYSTEM. BLIND WELL. THANK YOU
ABOUT WE RUN BEHALF OF APPLY-
FIRST ON THE HAPPENED BUT
INVERNAL THE FUND BUT IT WELL
TELL. ALLEY ATWATER POLLUTION
HELP HELP ENTERPRISES THE QUITE
RIVERLAND TRUST AND SINGLE
CONSERVATION. THE FUNDING FOR
THE PART BECAUSE- MULTI BENEFIT
LAND RECORD PROBE. THE
GOVERNOR'S. FORTY MILLION
REPORTER SHORT OF DEMAND
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING ABOUT A
PLAN WILL BE. ARGUED THAT THE
PROJECT WOULD BE RETIRED IN THE
COMING YEARS TO TAKE THAT. FIRST
ROUND OF THE APPLICATIONS ALONE
TOTALED OUT OVER A HUNDRED
ELEVEN MILLION. AND PEOPLE ARE
ALREADY LYING IN THE BACKGROUND
WE THEREFORE URGE THE ASSEMBLY
TO ALIGN CONTENT PROPOSED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. NEXT TIME YOU
HAVE TEACHER CONSERVANCY TROUT
UNLIMITED. CALTRAIN OUT NEW
VIRAL DEFENSE FIND. REPORT THE
PROPOSED FORTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR DROUGHT RESILIENCE
WHICH IS A GOOD STEP FORWARD.
TOWARD PROVIDING THE RESEARCH WE
NEED TO DEAL WITH. MORE FREQUENT
TRIED. THE CLIMATE CHANGE BRINGS
DATE. WE NEED BOLD INVESTMENT
NOW TO ADDRESS ON GOING TROUT
MEDIATE NEED MORE IMPORTANTLY
NEED TWENTY TO PREPARE FOR THE
FUTURE SO WE CAN TAKE MORE
EFFICIENT. EFFECTIVE ACTIONS
WHEN DROPPED HER. PHYSICALLY IN
REGARDS THAT QUESTION POSED BY
THE MAYOR BENNETT EARLIER WE ASK
FOR FUNDING TO BE ALLOCATED TO
THE DIVISION OF WATER RIGHT THE
WATER BOARD. THE STAFF WAS A
PERMANENT DROUGHT SECTION. THE
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY EMPLOYEES
COULD PLAN FOR AND REACT DRY
CONDITIONS BEFORE IT'S TOO LATE.
FINALLY ON BEHALF BROWN CAME
FORTY SUPERVISOR FOR DISTRICT
TWO NOTHING COUNTY. ARMY TRUNK
REPORT OF A TWO POINT TWO
MILLION FOR WILDLIFE RESPONSE
MANAGEMENT AT DFW. URGING THAT
THE FUNNY BE EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
OUT THANKS COUNTY WHICH BORDERS
BATTLE BASIN AND IT'S LOCKED AND
THOUSANDS OF ACRES OF HABITAT
LAST YEAR GET THE CAMERA HE
CALLED ARE FIRED. AND AS A
RESULT OF THE INTER MATIC
INCREASE IMPERATIVE. IN ITS
RESIDENTIAL AREAS THANK YOU. WHY
THIRD. MISTER CHAIRMAN BRANDON
TO ON BEHALF THE CAP POLICE
CONTROL A SENSE GIVEN THE
HISTORY SUPPORT THE MAYOR MISSES
A SICK OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH BY NOT INVESTING
MORE FUNDING INTO COST EFFECTIVE
AIR QUALITY PROGRAMS
AGRICULTURAL DIESEL REPLACEMENTS
AND UPGRADES WERE FINAL PROGRAM
IN THE EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION PROGRAM
WE APPRECIATE THE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IN FUNDING FOR FARMERS
IN THE JANUARY BUDGET
RESPECTFULLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
INCREASE THAT AMOUNT SECOND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE JANUARY
BUDGETS PROPOSED FIFTY MILLION
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF AB SIX
SEVENTEEN. HOWEVER DESPITE
ADDITIONAL COMMUNITIES BEING
ADDED THIS IS THE SAME AMOUNT IS
AS IN PEVIOUS YEARS WHICH HAS
BEEN INSUFFICIENT TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE STATE
MANDATED PROGRAM WELL A PLEASE
THE MEASURE OF ASIAN ADDS TWENTY
MILLION FOR PROGRAM INCENTIVES
IT'S STILL SIXTY MILLION LAST
AND LAST YEAR A TWENTY 3% CUT.
ALL INCLUDED YOU TO INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR THE WOULD. THAT
PROGRAM. ACROSS THE FACT PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES INCENTIVES FOR
RESIDENTS TO REPLACE DIRTY- WILL
TARGETING DEVICES WITH CLEANER
DEVICES. AND FINALLY EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TO WILDFIRE SMOKE
IMPACT IS AN INCREASINGLY
CRITICAL NEED. TO THE LACK OF
FUNDING AIR DISTRICTS ARE
LIMITED IN THEIR ABILITY TO DO
THE JOB WE REQUEST TEN MILLION
AND HAVE SHARED INFORMATION WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF ON HOW RESOURCES
COULD BE INVESTED. AND TAKING
MISTER CHAIR FOR ONLY BEING A
GENTLEMAN. HE WILL BE MISSED.
THANK YOU. BLIND THIRTY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
AND THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE TO
ACCELERATE FUNDING FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE AND THE
STRUCTURE AND EQUITY BATES CLEAN
. GRABS WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR
FREE TRANSIT THAT ONE AT ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION TO HELP PAY
UTILITY BILLS. AND THE NINE
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION. FOR
DISTRIBUTED SOLAR AND STORAGE
ADDITIONALLY WE APPRECIATE THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSALS FOR MUCH
NEEDED INVESTMENTS INTO VARIOUS
BOARDS AGENCIES TO FURTHER
THIRTY BY THIRTY AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCE. HOWEVER WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PASS THE FINAL
BUDGET THAT INCLUDES
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE INVESTMENT
THAN THIRTY BY THIRTY AND
COASTAL RESILIENCE. THAT'S MORE
IN LINE WITH WHAT THE SENATE
PROPOSED IN ITS CLIMATE BUDGET.
FINALLY VERY COULD THAT THE
ENERGY RESERVE PROPOSAL WILL
PROP UP THE POLLUTING FOSSIL
FUEL INFRASTRUCTURE WHEN WE NEED
WHEN WE NEED TO TRANSITION AND
MEDIA LAY AWAY FROM THESE
TECHNOLOGIES. AND THAT THE
PROPOSED FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR WATER STORAGE PROJECT WILL
FIND ECOLOGICALLY IRRESPONSIBLE
PROJECTS LIKE SITE THROUGHOUT
THE PARK THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE- THANK YOU. LINE.
FORTY AFTERNOON EVERYONE UP
BRING THE GRAVES OF THE SENATE
ACTED FOUNDATION WITH SUPPORT
AND APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAY REVISIT
VERSION BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR ITS
INVESTMENT INTO THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE STATE PARKS
STATE CONSERVANCY AND DEPARTMENT
OF CONSERVATION TO FURTHER
THIRTY BY THIRTY AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCE WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ONE HUNDRED
MILLION TO SUPPORT TRIBAL
PARTNERSHIP HOWEVER WE URGE THAT
THE FINAL BUDGET INCLUDES
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT THE SENATE HAS PROPOSED IN
ITS CLIMATE BUDGET INCLUDING AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THIRTY BY THIRTY AND THREE
BILLION FOR COASTAL RESILIENCE.
WE ALSO URGE THAT THE FINAL
BUDGET INCLUDES ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TWO HUNDRED MILLION A
YEAR IN ADDITION TO THE TRIBAL
FUNDING TO SUPPORT CAPACITY
BUILDING FOR ORGANIZATIONS
WORKING ON THE GROUNDS TO
IMPLEMENT THIRTY BY THIRTY
PARTICULARLY AND CLIMATE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
ADDITIONALLY WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER A 50%
INVESTMENT SATISFIED FOR
BIODIVERSITY CONSERVATION ACTION
FOCUSED ON CLIMATE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AS ONE APPROACH TO
ENSURE COMMUNITIES WHO
HISTORICALLY HAVE SEEN LITTLE OR
NO CONSERVATION INVESTMENTS HAVE
ASKED THAT THE FUNDING FOR THE
ACQUISITION AND OR RESTORATION
OF LAND AND WATER. CONSERVATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH. BLIND
THING. GOOD AFTERNOON- SPEED
CRUISER CHRISTIANITY ON THE
APPLE MAIL THE CARDIO IN THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE I'M CALLING TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S- MAY REVISING
COMMITMENT TO- TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE- HOWEVER- WE
WOULD LIKE TO POINT TO THE
SENATE- TRANSPORTATION PLAN THE
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS A DAY
PROPOSES PARTNER PACKAGE WE
THINK THAT TAKES ADVANTAGE OF
THE SURPLUS AND BEGAN WHEN HE
CONSTRAINTS TO INVEST IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AND LASTLY- A LETTER SAYING
PROJECTED ATP PROGRAM THE
APPLICATION THERE THAT'S BEEN
THERE QUITE A FEW BILLION AND A
THIRTEEN POINT EIGHT. FOUR RAIL-
PROJECTS FOR SAN JOSE IT'S- THE
BARGE FACE TO EXTENSION- THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE AND NOT LOSE
FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED- TO THE PROJECT- PLAN
ABLE TO SECURE STATE MATCHING
DOLLARS SO AGAIN WANTED CHEN
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR- THE
CONVERSATION GOING AROUND
BARRAGE EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS- BUT AT THIS POINT-
THE SENATE AND ARE REPRESENTS I
THINK US COMMERCIAL BLAST.
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU. PINE
CREEK DETAILED. SH HELLO AND-
THIS MARY TALKED IN AMERICA
CITIZEN AND IT INTO A FOR THE
GOVERNOR THIRTY BY THIRTY
EXECUTIVE AND THE PATH TO BY
THIRTY- I REALLY THEM MAY REFER
BUDGET AND FOR THE AND- I WOULD
PROTECTS TRAVEL PARTNERSHIPS
ACCESS TO NATURE PER UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. ALL THAT WILL
PREPARE THIRTY PAST THIRTY AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCE I ALONG WITH
SO MANY OTHERS- AND THESE CALLS
URGE THAT THE FINAL BUDGET
INCLUDES SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS ALONG THE LINES OF
THE SENATE PROPOSAL IN ITS
CLIMATE BUDGET THIS INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THIRTY BY THIRTY AND THREE
BILLION FOR COASTAL RESILIENCE.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY AND I
THINK THE SENATE'S PROPOSAL
REFLECTS THE SCALE OF WHAT IS
NEEDED TO ACHIEVE CALIFORNIA'S
THIRTY ABOUT THIRTY AN HOUR
CLIMATE RESILIENCE GOALS THANK.
YOU SO MUCH BY. FIVE FORTY
THREE. GOOD MORNING TO WE ARE
LEAVENED WITH SUPPLY- ENERGY IS-
CAL SH WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED FUNDING FOR THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY WHICH WILL HELP
ACCELERATE EFFORTS TO REDUCE
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS.
CHINA'S AROUND THE COURT THE
WORLD SAY THAT THIS IS THE MOST
URGENT THING WE CAN DO TO TACKLE
CLIMATE CHANGE AND ACCORDING TO
THE L. A. O. IN THE AIRPORT.
INVESTMENTS IN ORGANIC WASTE
ENERGY ARE ALSO THE SINGLE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE OF ALL OF THE
STATE'S CLIMATE INVESTMENT. WE
ALSO SUPPORT FUNDING FOR
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION BUT THAT
FUNDING SHOULD NOT BE LIMITED TO
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO INCREASE HYDROGEN
FROM ALL SB ONE HUNDRED ELDERLY
BE SOURCES. PARTICULARLY
HYDROGEN FROM ORGANIC WASTE
WHICH IS THE ONLY FORM OF
HYDROGEN THAT CAN PROVIDE CARBON
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS AND REDUCE
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE COULDN'T.
FINE WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCLUDE FUNDING SPECIFICALLY FOR
HORSE WASTE BIOMASS. UTILIZATION
THE STATE IS REQUIRED BY STATE
LAW TO DO FOREST NEED ON
MILLIONS OF ACRES. OVER THE NEXT
DECADE AND THAT IS GOING TO
GENERATE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
TONS OF COURSE WHICH THAT SHOULD
NOT BE PILED AND BURNED. WE
SHOULD BE PUTTING THAT WAYS TO
BENEFICIAL USE AND STATIC THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. PINE. FORTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FIFTY FAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA YOU CHRISTIAN P.
AND MAN MANAGEMENT COUNCIL WE
ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
GOVERNMENT'S RECOGNITION OF THE
GROWING DEMAND RESPONSE CAMPARI
IN ANY ENERGY RELIABILITY AND
APPRECIATE INCLUSION OF TWO
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE MILLION AND
THEN A REVISION TO THE PARK THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
DEVELOPING DEMAND SIDE GREAT
SUPPORT INITIATIVE. ON AN ENERGY
THEIR CALL EFFECTIVE MANNER
RESEARCH READY AVAILABLE TO BE
DEPLOYED TO AID CALIFORNIA GRAD.
BOTH RESOURCES REDUCE ENERGY
DEMAND ON THE GRID DURING PEAK
ENERGY TIMES. AT THE- THE DOUBLE
BY DURING THE AUGUST TWENTY
TWENTY GREAT CHALLENGES. LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
ON CONTINUING TO EXPAND THE
POTENTIAL FOR DEMAND RESPONSE.
IN ADDITION ON BEHALF HEALTH
STORM WATER PRECISION WE WOULD
LIKE TO BE FINALLY. FOR
STORMWATER CAPTURE AND
MANAGEMENT SIMILAR TO WHAT IS IN
THE CENTER CALLED THE- WE- THE
POINT FIVE BILLION POT OF WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
INCLUDING FUNDING STORMWATER
PROJECT. WILD URBAN STORMWATER
MANAGEMENT IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT WAY TO PROTECT OUR
PRECIOUS WATER EIGHT WHILE ALSO
INCREASING BALBOA WATER SUPPLY.
CLAMOR TO CAPTURE BERMAN ONE OF
THE MOST CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS FACING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I AM THIRTY FIVE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NOT
BROUGHT ON THE ETHNIC
COUNTERTERRORIST I WOULD JUST-
SAY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES
GALLAGHER'S BUDGET REQUESTED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN SURE PARADISE
ROAD MISTREATS OUR STATE FOR
CURRENT RED ROCK- YOU KNOW
THEY'RE STILL EXPERIENCING WHILE
ONGOING EFFECTS OF THE FIRE- ANY
YOU KNOW A RELATIVELY SMALL
ASKED TO MAKE A PRETTY DIFFERENT
I MEAN PEOPLE TRANSPORTATION
NEEDS WHICH ARE. ESSENTIAL TO
REBUILDING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. LINE. TWENTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR BALLING THE
NUMBERS DIFFICULTY IN THE
HAPPILY CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO MAKE
COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE WORLD
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA I PERSONALLY WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE TO
THE COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEE
STAFFER APPROVING ISSUE NUMBER
SEVENTY NINE RELATED TO CLEAN UP
LANGUAGE FOR AB TWENTY ONE-
EXCUSE ME- TWELVE A ONE TEAM
FROM LAST YEAR THIS SMALL BUT
IMPORTANT CHANGE WILL GO A VERY
LONG WAY TOWARD CLARIFYING HOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NEED TO
IMPLEMENT THIS BILLS. SECONDLY
WE ARE DISAPPOINTED TO NOT THE
FUNDING FOR SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE LOCALS TO. FRANCE TO HELP
CITIES AND COUNTIES IMPLEMENT
THE LANDMARK METHANE REDUCTION
LAW. THAT WE URGE THE ASSEMBLY
TO INCLUDE A HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION FOR THIS PURPOSE IN
THEIR FINAL BUDGET PROPOSAL. TO
MAKE SURE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
IMPLEMENT THIS WALK QUICKLY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WINE. FORTY
SIX. THE NUMBERS THIS IS MEGAN
CLEVELAND GOT INTO CONTENT HE
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON
THE REVISED. EIGHT THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS INCLUDED.
IRVING DROUGHT RESILIENCY ON ON
LAND AND I CRY BURKE HABITAT
UTILIZING TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FUNDING THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES DEPARTMENT ONE FIVE
MADE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
THE BIRD RETURNS PROGRAM
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
RECOGNITION PARTNER PROGRAMS
THEY SUPPORT. YOU THANK THEM
INTERNET HOW QUICKLY THE PROGRAM
CAN BE DEPLOYED AT AN
UNPRECEDENTED SCALE AS OF
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TO THE
CORPORATE PROGRAMS HAVE PROVIDED
OVER FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES
AVOCAT. ACTED OUT THE FUNDING
INCLUDED IN THE REVISED
DISAPPOINTING AFTER RESPONSE
APARTMENT THE DALLAS AND NETWORK
AND THEY CAN MAKE CONSERVATION
PROGRAM SUPPORT THE HABITAT
NEEDED TO MAKE TRADED WATER IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH CAN BE TAILORED
TO KEEP NATION CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITY. ADDITIONALLY TNT
AND- FOR IS NOT PROVIDED.
CALIFORNIA THIRTY BY THIRTY NAY
THEN BY ARE. ALL CONSERVING SIX
NINE ACRES. EIGHT YEAR. MEET
THIS TARGET IN THE EARLY THE
STATE CAN ONE BILLION TO THE
COURT IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
THIRD THIRTY IN. AB AND TO
PROTECT PRIVACY.
SERVICES ALL THE STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE NINE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLAR PACKAGE FOR
EQUITABLE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION AND PROPOSAL WE
HOPE TO SEE IN THE FINAL BUDGET
PACKAGE. EQUITABLY CARBONITE IN
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INSPECTOR
WILL BE CRITICAL TO MEETING OUR
CLIMATE GOALS AND COOLING
PROBLEMS THAT ARE MOST PEOPLE
ARE FULL COMMUNITIES. WE ARE
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSED. AN EXTREME HEAT
SET ASIDE TO CONSTRUCT AN
UPGRADE COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
CENTER REQUESTING A TOTAL OF ONE
BILLION. FOR THE CENTERS THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE THE MORNING CARE
BOMB AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER MY NAME
IS KEN THAT SECOND I AM CALLING
IN ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA TROUT
WE- ARE IN THE FORTENBERRY.
THANKFUL FOR. INDEED WE CAN'T
NAY REVISED YOU MINISTRATION
PARTICULARLY. EDUCATION WILDLIFE
PROTECTION RESTORATION FUNDING
IN THE JOB PACKAGE THAT INCLUDES
THE HUNDRED MILLION PROTECTING
AND THEN RESTORATION AND THREE
POINT THREE MILLION FRESH
PACKAGING COMMENTS THAT WERE
TRIED- AN ACCOUNT. LIKE A LINE
ECONOMIC- WITHIN A GIVEN BANK
YOUNGER NOW BOTH IN WRITING AND
PERSON PRETTY. 50% INVESTMENT
SATISFIED PROVIDE CONSERVATION
ACTION FOCUSED THE CLIMATE ON
OUT. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFYING ONE THAT
. THANK YOU. BY. FIFTY FOUR. HI
THIS IS MY WHAT THE ASSEMBLY.
YEP FIVE ABOUT THIS IS NO
JACKSON WITH THE ASSEMBLY CLEAN
ENERGY. I ASSEMBLY KLINKENBERG
WOULD WASTE- FROM FARM AND
FOREST Q. CARBON NEGATIVE
HYDROGEN AS WELL AS RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR- WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR GREEN HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION BUT WE REQUEST THAT
ALSO INCLUDES. ALL CARBON
NEGATIVE HYDROGEN INCLUDING
HYDROGEN FROM ORGANIC REYES.
FIVE MINUTES FROM MILLION
DOLLARS IS LIMITED TO ELECT
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN THE STATE
THE DEATH FROM TELEVISING CARBON
NEGATIVE HYDROGEN FROM WORK.
WHICH ALSO. REDUCES FOREST HILLS
HIGH HAZARD THREE USING WORD
PROBLEM. HI HOW AREAS OF POOREST. THANK YOU THANK YOU. PINE.
SIXTY ONE. SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HI MANY OF MY R.
RANCHO FROM AMERICA LUNG
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THE
COMMENTS AND TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS AS YOU MOVE FORWARD
WITH OUR STATE BUDGET WE ASK
THANK YOU CHARACTERS CRIME IT
AIR QUALITY AND EQUITY PROGRAMS
THAT PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
CALIFORNIANS LEARNED LONG HELD-
ARE BASED ON OUR STATE OF THE
ART COULDN'T COME BACK
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS- CREATES
THE MOST UNHEALTHY AIR IN THE
NATION AND WE KNOW THAT BOTH
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY TRANSPORTATION
POLLUTION. FOR THESE REASONS WE
SUPPORT THE CONGRESSIONAL CLOSER
TO THEIR OWN VERSION
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS CLEAN
ANYTHING BAD AND BE A COLORATION
OF THEIR MISSION FROM PASSENGER
TO MEDIUM. AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES AND IS THAT THE FIVE
ARE ALL CAN'T THAT KEEP IN MIND
EQUITY OR IN SHOULD BE IN A FOR.
OF THE EFFORT THEY EASY I MAKE.
CLEAN CARS BROUGHT FOUR BEING.
TO EVERY DISTRICT TWO. EXISTING
THAT SUPPORT THAT FROM YOUR HOME
BURKE MEET THE NEEDS OF LOS. WE
ARE ALSO. THE. I WAS THE THAT'S
NOT BAD INCLUDES FOR MORE ACTIVE
CHECK. TRANSITIONING TRANSIT
THROUGH THEIR MISSION AND
IMPROVING SERVICE THANK YOU. WHY
NOT THANK. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
BLOOM MEMBERS PAUL MASON WITH
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST FOR GOING
THANK YOU THE WIND BLOWN FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND FOR BEING SUCH A
CONSISTENT CHAMPION FOR WILDLIFE
IN A WILDLIFE HABITAT
CONNECTIVITY AND WATERSHED
RESTORATION WORLD REALLY GONNA
MISS YOU OPTIONAL FOR AFFECT THE
PREVIOUS THE ALLOCATIONS THE
WHILE THE CONSERVATION BOARD
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE CONSERVANCIES
AND FOR TROUBLE ACTION ON THIRTY
BY THIRTY BUT THE SCALE OF THE
CONSERVATION AND CLIMATE NEEDS
INCLUDING THE GOLD THE STATE
ALREADY ESTABLISHED SUCH AS
THIRTY BY THIRTY. REALLY DEMAND
SUBSTANTIALLY GREATER
INVESTMENTS THEN THE SIGNIFICANT
WESTMINSTER ALREADY IN THE MAY
REVISED- THE SENATE PROPOSAL IS
MORE PROPERLY SCALED TO THE NEED
AND THE SURPLUS THEY WERE
WORKING WITH THIS YEAR I DO I
BRIEFLY HIGHLIGHT THE VALUE
MAKING COORDINATED REGIONAL
INVESTMENTS ARE SOURCE
WATERSHEDS WHERE ACTION CAN
BENFIT WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY
WATER SECURITY FIRE SAFETY IN
CLIMATE MITIGATION
SIMULTANEOUSLY AGAIN THE SENATE
PROPOSES TARGETED ACTIONS
WATERSHED RESILIENCY AND WE URGE
THE ASSEMBLY SUPPORT THE SAME
SORTS OF REGIONAL MULTI BENEFIT. NATURE BASED PROJECTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I NEED SIXTY
BILL. GOOD MORNING JERRY NUMBER
IF POSSIBLE OKAY ON BEHALF OF
THE LEAN MANUFACTURING
INSTRUCTABLE ARE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE NINE
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR STATEWIDE LOW INCOME
BUILDING RETROFIT THE
COMBINATION PROGRAM THANK YOU.
LINE. SIXTY THREE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS MARK
FENSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF
CINEMA WATER IN STRONG SUPPORT
AT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
TEN MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING FOR
THE ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS FORECAST
INFORMED RESERVOIR OPERATIONS
PROGRAM IS ONE OF THE BEST WAYS
THAT WE CAN MAGYARS MODERNIZE
OUR CURRENT WATER SYSTEM AND
RESULT IN MORE WATER FROM THAT
CURRENT SYSTEM. SOME WATER'S
BEEN ABLE TO HOLD BACK THOUSANDS
OF ACRE FEET THAT OTHERWISE WE
WOULD HAVE HAD TO RELEASE WE HAD
MODERNIZE THE WAY WE OPERATE OUR
RESERVOIRS WE APPRECIATE THAT
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT FROM ITS
ONGOING PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
THANK FORTY NINE. THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS MARK MCDONALD ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS- WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT TO
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION PRETTY
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM-
WE FEEL THAT'S A GOOD START BUT
CCAC SUPPORT CHAIR PREPAYMENT
BUDGET LETTER ASKING FOR ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY SHOVEL WORK THE BIKE
AND PEDESTRIAN PROJECT CAN BE
CONSTRUCTED. BOB ON THE OLYMPICS
WE ASK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PRIORITIZE TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION IN FUNDING TO SUPPORT
TRANSIT PROJECTS THAT WILL
SUPPORT OLYMPIC COULD LEAVE A
LASTING POSITIVE LIKE IT'S THREE
PER CALIFORNIA A PRIMARY WE ASK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
AUGMENTING THE IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS CREATED AND B. ONE
ESPECIALLY THE TRADE CORRIDOR
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM WHICH FUNDS
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS ON
TRADE CORRIDORS OF NATIONAL AND
REGIONAL SIGNIFICANT. WHICH WILL
HELP SOLVE THE BOTTLENECK AT THE
PORT AND IMPROVE OUR FREIGHT AND
GOODS MOVEMENT. NETWORK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE THIRTEEN.
THE MORNING CARE AND MEMBER OF
BROWN'S WALKING A BUNCH ABOUT
AIR QUALITY COALITION I REQUEST
THAT YOU RECONSIDER THE
REJECTION OF THE CARB OFFICE THE
PATIENT EQUITY AND HAVE THE ITEM
OPEN THE BALL ONLY CALENDAR
FEEDBACK AND- REPORTER- FUNDING
OPERATIONALIZE IN RACIAL EQUITY
WITHIN CARD PROGRAM I AM IN FACT
BECAUSE I'VE ABOUT. FOUR ONE BY
MICHAEL DUNBAR DUFFY PROGRAM THE
CARD CARD PART OF THE EFFORT-
EQUITY IN MITCHELL JUSTICE OUR
PLAYS AN ESSENTIAL OVERSIGHT
ROLE IN MUST DO MORE TO. THE AIR
PARTICULARLY AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES AND THEN THE. FINAL VALUE ONE OF THE MOST.
EVERYTHING IN THE NATION THE
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE
CARD HE ACTING IN AND DURING
SURE INTEGRATE- EVERYBODY AND
ALL OF OUR DIVISION ARE GRAHAM
RESEARCH RELATED IMPOSSIBLE. WE
ARE JUST NEEDED TO FIND A QUIET
SPOT TO OPERATE. RACIAL EQUITY A
CARTON THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
KNEW SIX FIVE. GOOD MORNING
JERRY CAN MEMBERS THIS IS FOR
PROUD STOP BECAUSE THEY CAN WE
APPRECIATE SIX SACRAMENTO-FUNDING AND GOVERNOR'S FOR
INDUSTRY HOWEVER THE PROGRAM IS
SEVERELY UNDERFUNDED AND WE ASK
THAT YOU PROVIDE INCREASED AND
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING TO COVER
ACTUAL PROGRAM COST THE NUMBER
OF COMMITTEES IN THE PROGRAM HAS
GROWN AND WILL CONTINUE TO GROW
THEIR DISTRICTS ARE WORKING AT A
DEFICIT TO ADMIT THE STATE
MANDATED PROGRAM. WE APPRECIATE
THE EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
INCENTIVE FUNDING INCLUDED
ESPECIALLY THE ADDITIONAL TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS ADDED TO THE MAY
REVISED HOWEVER OVERALL THE
TOTAL ALLOCATION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS STILL
REDUCTION FROM WHAT IS A
MANDELBLIT PREVIOUS YEARS WE ASK
THAT YOU PROVIDE INCREASE
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING TO
PRIORITIZE A MISSION REDUCTIONS
THAT PROTECT THE HEALTH OF THE
STATE'S DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. SIGNIFICANT
SUSTAINABLE INCENTIVE FUNDING IS
CRITICAL FOR MEETING HEALTH
BASED FEDERAL AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS AND EXHILARATING
SORELY NEEDED. NEAR TERM
EMISSION REDUCTIONS. WHAT
FUNDING ZERO HEAVY DUTY ZERO
MISSION TECH. BE DEVELOPED
MASTER IN THE- HOW GIVEN OUR NAY
TO PROTECT HEALTH. WE SUPPORT
BUT TO REPLY HEAVY DUTY DEAL.
WITH NEAR ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS
THAT ARE LOWER COST MORE COST
EFFECTIVE AND PROVIDE MORE
IMMEDIATE AIR POLLUTION AND GHG
EMISSION REDUCTIONS. IN SURPLUS
AT THE PLEASURE AND HONOR TO
WORK WITH YOU OVER THESE PAST
YEARS. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. LINE. SIXTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING GENTLEMEN NUMBER SIX OF
THREE SEPARATE WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL NONPROFIT PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENT WE HOLD THE
COMPLICATED STATUS BUT THE
INTERNATIONAL MARITIME
ORGANIZATION CHAPTER ONE OF THE
WORST POLLUTERS IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE LAST YEAR'S CARGO
CONDUCTION UP TEMPE REPORTS HAVE
CAUSED AN INCREASE IN
NONCOMMISSIONED BUT THE CRUMBLE
INTO A FIVE POINT EIGHT MILLION
PASSENGER CARS- OCEANGOING
VESSELS AND HOVERCRAFT BERRIES
AND HOW BOTH ARE ONE OF THE TOP
THREE CANCER CAUSING EMISSIONS
AT PORTS. WE'VE GOT COORDINATOR
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF COVER
CROP WROTE CARBON WE ARE PLEASED
THAT CARBON DR DETECTION
STRONGER RULES ON SETTING UP THE
FIRST YEAR MISSION CENTER PART
IN THE NATION AND THE WATER WE
SUPPORT THE NEW REVISED FOR
INTERMISSION TRANSPORTATION WERE
URGING THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
FINAL BUDGET TO INCLUDE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FUNDING
FOR- TO HELP- XCELERATED YOUR
MISSION VESSEL SEGMENS IN THE
SHIPPING INDUSTRY THE PROPOSAL
SUPPORTED BY HEALTH COMMUNITY
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
BAFFLED BUILDERS. WE ARE ALSO
SUPPORT OF A FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A PART
ELECTRIFICATION IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE ADEQUATE ZERO EMISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR SHIPS THANK
YOU. SO MUCH. THANK YOU. PINE
CREEK FIVE. THANK MELISSA CORTEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CREATE A
NEW C. E. C. CITING OPTION FOR
WIND SOLAR AND LARGE STORAGE
PROJECTS IN LESS THAN SIX YEARS
TWENTY FIVE GIGAWATTS OF NEW
RENEWABLE CONTENDER GO LOTS OF
NEW STORAGE MUST BE BUILT TO
STAY ON PACE WITH OUR SB ONE
HUNDRED REQUIREMENTS CREATING A
NEW SIDING OPTION IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL TO GETTING THESE
PROJECTS BUILT AN ONLINE NOT
JUST FOR CLIMATE GOALS BUT FOR
RELIABILITY GOALS. PLACING
AUTHORITY WITH THE ESTATE AGENCY
IS NOT WITHOUT PRECEDENT THE
ENERGY COMMISSION ALREADY HAS
EXCLUSIVE OR WAS GIVEN EXPLICIT
AUTHORITY OVER JURISDICTION FOR
THERMAL PLANTS SIMILARLY THE QC
APPROVES NEW POWER LINES THE
COMMISSION'S REVIEW IS
COMPREHENSIVE AND RIGOROUS AND
FULLY CONSIDERS LOCAL CONCERNS
AS ALL LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS WILL
PARTICIPATE IN THE SEQUEL
PROCESS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
HONEST AND ASK YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU. BY. SIXTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON
THAT SUNDAY THAT ALL MEN ON
BEHALF OF IMPERIAL COUNTY TO
EXPRESS THEIR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE LITHIUM VALLEY PROPOSALS AND
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINES SEVEN DAY. GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS
POWER TRITON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE SUPPORT OF ITEM THIRTY
THREE THEIR RESOURCE FOR THE TOP
OF THE BRIDGE FOR EQUITY.
POSITION THE FUNDED WOULD
DIRECTLY AFFECT HOW WELL THE
COOKING PLAN IMPLEMENTED HOPE
FILLED THE AIR RESOURCE BOARD'S
MANDATE VENTURE THAT THE COMPACT
HEAVY DO NOT DISPROPORTIONATELY
HARM LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES IN
FACT AFFECT THEM. THE COPING
PLAN THE UPON PUBLIC HOW DISCUSS
THE MANY INEQUITIES HELP
OUTCOMES THE CLIMATE CHANGE ON
LOW INCOME. AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WITH CARBON KNOWLEDGES
OVERLAP LARGELY WITH CLIMATE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. THERE
ARE REPORTS OF BOARD PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO HELP ACHIEVE THE
GOAL OF EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION
OF BENEFITS ACROSS THE STATE.
ONE OF THE KEY AREAS FOR FURTHER
ACTION IS FOR CARTOON GROUP
OUTREACH TO CLIMATE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE MITIGATION
PROJECTS SUCH AS EXTREME HEAT.
RESEARCH COMMUNITIES. OF COURSE
THESE PROMISES REMAIN EMPTY AND
WHAT THERE IS STAFF DEDICATED TO
ENSURING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PLAN IS THAT GOOGLE THANK
YOU. LINE. SIXTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STAFFERS THANK YOU CHAIR REAL
ROOM FOR YOUR EXTRAORDINARY
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HUMANE
LEADERSHIP ON THE FIELD- THIS IS
TWO WEEKS LATER FOR FEARLESS
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE CLIENT
FIRST THE OCCIDENTAL ARTS AND
ECOLOGY CENTER STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR A
NEW BEAVER RESTORATION PROGRAM
AT THE DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING TO BRING NATURE'S
ENGINEERS BACK TO CONSISTENT
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. SECOND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MUSEUM
URGES YOU TO INCLUDE A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL AND
HISTORICAL ENDOWMENT AND MUSEUM
GRANT PROGRAM TO THAT MUSEUMS
AND CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS ACROSS
THE STATE CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO TITLE ONE
SCHOOLS AND CHILDREN IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND HELP
CULTURAL OFF THAT AND EDUCATE
THE PUBLIC ABOUT CRITICAL ISSUES
FACING CALIFORNIANS SUCH AS
CLIMATE CHANGE. FINALLY THE
NATIONAL WILDLIFE FEDERATION
ACTOS ASSEMBLY WOMAN FRIEDMAN
SUPPORT FOR BIGGER INVESTMENTS
IN WILDLIFE CROSSINGS AND THANK
GOVERNOR NEWSOM PROPOSING A
FINAL TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE WALLIS ANNENBERG WILDLIFE.
CROSSING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BY SIXTY. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WILL BE ASKED
TO LEAVE SHOP ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT THE DISTRICT
COURTS THE EXPLORATION OF
FUNDING FOR THE CLEAN CARDS FOR
ALL PROGRAMS HOWEVER WE BELIEVE
THAT MOST OF THAT FUNDING SHOULD
GO TO THE EXISTING
OVERSUBSCRIBED PROGRAMS THAT
CURRENTLY SERVE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THE REMAINDER OF
THE FIND COULD THEN GO TO
CONTINUE PROGRAMS AS AS PROPOSED
IN THE BUDGET. IN ADDITION THE
DISTRICT OFFICE SUPPORT FUNDING
FOR SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE
SPECIFICALLY FUNDING FOR
ELECTRIC AG EQUIPMENT INCLUDING
FORKLIFTS YARD. TRACTOR AND
UTILITY VEHICLE. LASTLY ON THE
OF AN OF CLIENTS WITH MATTERS IN
FRONT OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE I'D
LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR HIS WORK AS CHAIR I TEACHER
MUCH HUMOR GRACE AND LET THEM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LINE WE'RE
GONNA OPERATOR GOING TO PAUSE
FOR JUST A MOMENT- WELL LET OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN MAKES A
BRIEF STATEMENT AND THAT
GLASPELL THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD I
SAY WAIT I PER I PROMISED TO BE
VERY BRIEF- CALLERS WHO ARE
WAITING I JUST WANTED TO THANK
MISTER CHAIR- FOR YOUR GREAT
WORK THIS YEAR FOR YOUR THOUGHT
FOR LEADERSHIP OF THIS COMMITTEE
IT HAS BEEN A JOY TO SERVE ON
THIS COMMITTEE WITH YOU SIR AT
THIS INCREDIBLE STAFF-
SHEPHERDING. ALL OF THESE ITEMS
THROUGH THE PROCESS I JUST
WANTED TO VERY BRIEFLY VERY
BRIEFLY COMMENT I WANT TO THANK
THE STAFF FOR THE B. C. B. C.
FUNDING APPRECIATE THE STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATION I WANT TO PUT A
STRONG PLUGIN FOR CALTRAIN
ELECTRIFICATION THERE'S NEVER
BEEN A BETTER TIME THAN NOW TO
COMPLETE ELECTRIFICATION OF THE
NORTHERN SECTION OF HIGH SPEED
RAIL AND THAT WILL BE- THE
CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION BOOK
AND PROJECT WILL BE A MEDIALLY
USEFUL- TO BAY AREA COMMUTERS
I'M HOPEFUL. THAT WE'LL BE ABLE
TO MODIFY THE T. I. R. C. P. THE
TRANSIT INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL
PROGRAM TO ALLOW LARGE PROJECTS
LIKE CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION TO
REAPPLY FOR FUNDING INCLUDING
COST OVERAGES I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO DON'T SUPPORT FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES GOING TOWARD CLIMBERS
EIGHTY PROJECTS AND FOLLOW UP ON
THE WORK INVESTMENTS COMMITTED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET. IMMEDIATE AND
INVESTMENT OF THIS SORT OF KIND
IS INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL
GUARD AGAINST CLIMATE RELATED
DISASTERS THAT WE KNOW ARE
COMING AND JUST A FINAL NOTED
LOVE TO SEE SOME A COMMITMENT OF
RESOURCES TO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OF OUR STATE PARKS
AND AGAIN- GRATEFUL MISTER CHAIR
IT'S BEEN AND IT'S BEEN A JOY TO
SERVE ON THIS COMMITTEE UNDER
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND WITH THAT
BACK TO YOU AND OUR CALLERS
THANK YOU SIR. BEEN. GOOD TO
HAVE YOU ALONG FOR THE RIDE SIR.
CALIBRATOR HE THREE YEAR LINE
NOW ALL. MISTER CARE NUMBERS IF
MILLION NUMBER OF THE ON THE
LIGHTS CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
CREEPY DISSOCIATION SEVERAL
OTHER ACT CLIENTS I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY EXPRESSING OUR
SUPPORT SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR DROUGHT RELIEF TO
SMALL FARMERS FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE POLLINATOR
HABITAT PROGRAM. AND ALSO THE-
CONTINUED FUNDING FOR THE BE
SAFE PROGRAM EXTENSION THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE- IN
ADDITION WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL
AROUND OTHER PURCHASES SENIOR
WATER RIGHTS IN THE REVISED AND
WE DON'T NEED TO BE MORE
DISCUSSION- ON THIS TOP. AND
THEN FINALLY ON BEHALF OF BUT
YOU WATER DISH REQUIRED YOU CAN
AGREED ABOUT THE WATER AGENCY
ANTON GIVE ABOUT A MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE ADDITIONAL FUNDING OF UP TO
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
INCLUDING. FOR COUPONS FOR
MEDIATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER MOLINA. LINE. SEVENTY
ONE. A GOOD MORNING- CAN HELP
YOU KNOW ON THE BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA FUTURE DOUBLE TRUSTED
HELLO AMTRUST UPPER I JUST WANT
TO EXPRESS MY DEEP APPRECIATION
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- FOR YOUR
DOG PRESS FREE RIGHT. YES MY
LET'S KILL AND HE'S TELLING THE
MAIL MAN THE KILLED ME- WE'RE
HERE THAT WE ON THE STORY AND BY
FUNDING YOU CHAMPION AND SIR
BASED. EFFORT AT THE VFW AND IT
HAS BEEN TRANSFERRED THANK YOU-
I LIKE IT A LOT MY ARE BACK IN
BY THIRTY INCLINED RESILIENCE
BUT THOSE BY THE FOLKS YOU WITH
THAT NATIVE WITH AND ALL MADE
SENSE WE- YOU MINISTRATIONS
BUDGET. ARE PARTICULARLY THE
FUNDING FOR THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS DESERT
PROGRAM AND THE NEW BEAVER
RESTORATION PROGRAM BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT MORE CAN AND SHOULD
BE DONE INCREASING INVESTMENT-
TO FURTHER THIRTY BY THIRTY IN
TERMS OF FUNDING FOR
ACQUISITIONS EASEMENTS
RESTORATION VEGETATION MAPPING
AND CAPACITY BUILDING- I DON'T
ALS LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. REPORTER
REQUEST FOR AN ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED MILLION TODAY THE CITY
FOR WILDLIFE QUARTERS AND AFTER
ANOTHER HUNDRED MILLION TO THE
STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY FOR
LARGE OBSOLETE DAM REMOVAL.
MCCARTY MINISTRATIONS BY
PROPOSAL WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE
INVESTMENT THAN CONSERVANCY AND
FIRE RESILIENT BUT WE'D LIKE TO
SEE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD LAY OUT THAT ARE REPORTING
AN INCREASE. MONITORING THE
PROJECT IN THE STATE- SO WE CAN
UNDERSTAND AND LEARN FROM THE
PROJECT AND TODAY THAT ARE
HAPPENING. ON THE DROUGHT
PROPOSAL ON ABOUT THE DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE WE SUPPORT THE
FUNDING ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED FOR HUMAN WILDLIFE
CONFLICTS FAMINE RESTORATION
WILDLIFE WETLANDS RESTORATION
ETCETERA BUT WE DO NOT SUPPORT
THE FUNDING TO- FOR THE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT AND FINALLY
I JUST LIKE TO NOTE. THAT CAN'T
WE CAN'T REALLY SPEAK TO THE
POWER PLANT CITING AND WITHIN
VALLEY PROPOSALS RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE WE NEED TO SEE THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE SO I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO JUST SAY THAT
VIOLENCE IS NOT SUPPORT AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THOSE.
IMPORTS FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
AND AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CHEN CHAIRMAN GRAHAM FOR ALL. OF
YOUR LEADERSHIP FOR WILDLIFE.
THANK YOU TO BOTH OF YOU. WHAT
LINE SEVENTY EIGHT THE TALK. HI
IS PATRICK GOING BEHALF OF THE
MUNICIPAL ASSOCIATE. INTO OF THE
FUN PRODUCT REARED PAYMENT I FOR
HI SIX OUT BURKE THAT IS HELPED
OVER ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
ENERGY CUSTOMERS STATEWIDE
ADDRESS- BILL ASSISTANCE RELIEF
DURING THE CUBS AND PANDEMIC WE
HAVE TWO SUGGESTIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE ONE IS THAT WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO RELY ON TWO
DISTINCT- ACCOUNTING MECHANISMS
TO ENSURE THAT BY USING CC H.
AND P. IS- CAN ADMINISTER THE
FUNDS OFFICIALLY TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS AND TO- WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT FEDERAL
FUNDED THE SOURCE. OF FUNDS FOR
THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR CAP
SO THAT CUSTOMERS DO NOT
EXPERIENCE TAX ADVANTAGE UPON
RECEIVING THE FUNDS WERE STILL
AFFECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS ON THE WATER
ASSISTANCE PROVISION AS WELL AS
THE NUMEROUS OTHER WATER AND
ENERGY PROPOSALS AND CONTAIN. IT
AND EVERYBODY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- LINE. EIGHTY FOUR. WHY
NEEDED COULD HAVE YOUR WINTER
AND MEMBERS OPERATOR MEDINA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERROGATION DISTRICT HERE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE IN
THE WAY BUT ALSO HERE TO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
INVESTMENT IN THE LITHIUM
BATTERY AND THOSE FOR
TRANSMISSION AND THE KNOWN OUT
THERE MOST OF THE THREE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE. THIRTY
NINE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON- RATHER
GOOD MORNING- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ERIC LONELY REPRESENTING TO THE
SUCCESS OF A POSSIBLE AND WHAT
THAT DOES I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF FUNDING FOR OPERATE
OPERATIONALIZE THE RACIAL EQUITY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD- PARLAYED PARDON
WE CAN BE THE COLOR PLAYED BY
DISCORDANT- SHOULD BURDEN FOR
OVER A DECADE. ADVOCATE A CARD
WHICH SUGGESTS CALL A LETTER
BLOCK. PLEASE TAKE A LOOK TO GO
OUT IN THE TURN PROBLEMS RACIAL
AT INSTEAD AGENCY. JOB SCOPE
RELEASED LAST WEEK BACK OF THE
STATE CRIME STRATEGY BRING FOR.
EXISTING REYES EQUITY PLACE TO
BUT POLLUTION BURKE KING COLOR
MISCON IT IS VERY CONCERNING THE
CARDS WITH A AGAIN THE FUND. IS
THE- ONE POINT EIGHT FIVE POOR
AIR AIR POLLUTION CONTROL-
PUTTING FOR PERMANENT POSITIONS
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET AND ONE POINT EIGHT.
MILLION IT OUT FOR FUNDING FOR
ONGOING RACIAL EQUITY EFFORTS
INITIAL FOCUS ON RESEARCH
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS REGULATIONS.
AIR QUALITY PLANNING CLIMATE
CHANGE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BY
PARDON POWER LINE. EIGHTY HI
GOOD MORNING- THE CHAPLAIN AND
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RACHEL
HAYWARD I'M- THE REGULAR CITIZEN
IN CALIFORNIA AND- ALSO AND KIND
ACTIVISTS ASSOCIATED WITH A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS JUST WANTED TO
COMMENT THAT I'M I'M STRONGLY IN
FAVOR OF FUNDING FOR THIRTY BY
THIRTY AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE
INITIATIVES- BATTERED BASKING IN
CONSERVATION NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS AND INDIGENOUS AND
TRIBAL LAND SOVEREIGNTY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL TO
SUPPORT TRIBAL TO.
BUY LAND BACK TO RECLAIM LAND
AND TRADITIONAL AND ECOLOGICAL
STEWARDSHIP OF THOSE PLANS I
ALSO WOULD SUPPORT YOU KNOW
CONTINUING FUNDING- GIVEN HOW A
HUNDRED MILLION IT AT THE BACK
OF A HUNDRED MILLION IS NOT VERY
MUCH- ENOUGH FOR JUST ONE YEAR
ONLY- I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT AT THE LEGISLATURE WE CAN
CONSIDER A 50% INVESTMENT- SET
ASIDE FOR CONSERVATION ACTIONS
AND CLIMATE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. AS ONE APPROACH TO
ENSURE THAT WE NEED THE COLOR
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES OTHER GIVEN
HISTORICALLY LEFT OUT OF
CONSERVATION BASSMAN PATH ACCESS
TO THE FUNDING. DE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL AND ALSO THE
SENATE PROPOSAL AND EXPLAIN IT
BUDGET AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THIRTY BY
THIRTY AN ADDITIONAL THREE
BILLION FOR CUSTOMERS THAT
ENHANCE. THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING AT THIRTY BY. THIRTY
AND OTHER IMPORTANT CLIMATE
SOLUTION. PINE. EIGHTY FIVE.
HELLO THIS IS GREG- ON BEHALF OF
THE SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE CARPARK. AND WORK WITH THEM
WITH A BIPARTISAN GROUP OF
LEGISLATORS YOU GET UP EARLY
ACTION- PROPOSAL THAT WE NEED
FUNDING FOR- WE ENCOURAGE IT SUB
COMMITTEE TO PLAN THESE EARLY
ACTIONS WHICH WILL KEEP. TICKET
PRICES AFFORDABLE SO THAT
EVERYBODY CAN ENJOY OCEAN ACCESS
AND ALLOW THIRD IT IN YOU ARE
WORK WITH APPS ON A FEW- AND
OTHER NONPROFITS THAT SERVE
VETERANS AND DISABLED-
INDIVIDUALS. WE ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT- FUNDING ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES AND HARBOR CRAFT
AND ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH CARP
OVER THE COMING YEAR AND WE WILL
BE DOING A TECHNOLOGY REVIEW
WITH THEM. TO TRY AND MOVE TO
OUR TWENTY FORTY FIVE STATES SO
WE WANT TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH SOME OF THE OTHER MEMBERS
INCLUDING PACIFIC ENVIRONMENT-
WHERE WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
PRIORITY- ZERO MISSION DOLLARS
FLOWING TO THOSE THAT HAVE THE
EARLY IMPLEMENTATION. EIGHT AND
IT'S TAKEN CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
THAT THIS IS FUNDED OUTSIDE OF
CARL MOYER PROGRAM SO THAT WE
CAN MEET THE TIME FRAMES THAT
CAR PADS THAT. SO THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR TIME AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE. EIGHTY
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THERE TURN IT WOULD MEAN
A LOT HAPPENED SMITH SAID IT'S
ON BEHALF OF TURLOCK IRRIGATION
DISTRICT CALLING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE FUNDING FOR
FORECAST INFORMED RESERVOIR
OPERATION AND THE COLLECTION OF
AIRBORNE SNOW OBSERVATORY DATA
TO IMPROVE THE ACCURACY OF THE
RUNOFF FORECAST. IN ADDITION
TURLOCK IRRIGATION DISTRICT ALSO
SUPPORTIVE ABOUT THE FUNDING
PROPOSAL FIRST SOLAR
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS
ASSOCIATED WITH WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE ALSO CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SANTA MARGARITA WATER
DISTRICT EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT AND MONTEREY ONE WATER
YOU THINK CLOSER THE INCLUSION
OF A HUNDRED MILLION FOR WATER
RECYCLING IN THE MAY REVISE
HOWEVER GIVEN THE NEED AND
PIPELINE OF PROJECTS SHOVEL
READY WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
MONEY INCREASE CLOSER TO WHAT I
IN THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN TO THE
TUNE OF. SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BLIND. EIGHTY TWO. WHY NEEDED TO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO
BONTA LINE FOURTEEN. YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS DAN
JACOBSON- DIDN'T ARMY CALIFORNIA
AND I'M HERE AS A MEMBER OF THE
CHARGER HEAD CALIFORNIA WHICH
SPONSORED SB TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE
THE LEGISLATION THAT CREATED
CALIFORNIA'S SUITE OF
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAMS
AND ALSO PART OF THE INVESTING
CLEAN AIR CAMPAIGN. NOW MORE
THAN EVER. CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION STRATEGY NEEDS TO
CENTER O EQUITY WELL ALL
CALIFORNIANS YOU'RE FEELING THE
PINCH FROM THE GASOLINE PRICES
ARE DISADVANTAGED IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ARE FEELING THE PAIN
THE MOST. CALIFORNIA IS ALSO
HOME TO THE DIRTIEST CARE IN THE
NATION IN TRANSPORTATION IS THE
STATE'S NUMBER ONE SOURCE OF
POLLUTION. WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S NEWLY REVISED
PROPOSAL TO ACCELERATE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS THE
STATE'S RECORD SHATTERING BUDGET
SURPLUS GIVES CALIFORNIANS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST IN CLEAN
AIR. UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS
SPEEDING UP INVESTMENTS.
PARTICULARLY IN MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY SECTOR WILL YIELD
SIGNIFICANT CLIMATE HEALTH
BENEFITS WE DO HOWEVER HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAMS.
THE PROPOSED BUDGET THAT
ALLOCATES TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR FUTURE
STATEWIDE EXPANSION IN ONLY
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EXISTING PROGRAMS. WE BELIEVE
THAT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THESE
PROGRAMS WORK THE BEST WHEN THE
COMMUNITY GROUPS ARE ABLE TO
WORK AT THE COMMUNITY THAT'S
WHERE THEY ARE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE. IN WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS NUMBER SHOULD BE FLIPPED
THE EXISTING PROGRAMS HAVE
INTERMEDIATE NEEDS AND INVESTING
IN THEM WILL CREATE AN IMMEDIATE
BENEFITS FOR THE MOST POLLUTED
AREAS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE SEVENTY NINE. HELLO AND
THEN THE THIRD- I THINK CANADIAN
DOLLARS LAST WEEK BUT THEY HAVE
NOT HAD ANY- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY WHERE
COURAGE- IDEA ABOUT THE FASHION
AND THE PROPOSALS THAT RECOGNIZE
THE AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGE THAT
BASED. ON MANY OF OUR CUSTOMERS-
WE'RE IN HER GET BACK COLD. THAT
ARE PUTTING ON THE TABLE EIGHT.
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN BEEN BORN BY
OUR CUSTOMERS BUDGET RELIABILITY
VEHICLE AND EQUITABLE BUILDING
BE APARTMENT AGENT UNDESERVEDLY
RECORD PROPOSED ONE POINT TWO
BILLION FOR YOU CAN YOU QUALITY
CUSTOMER UNPAID BILLS THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA- PROGRAM IT WAS
FUNDED LAST YEAR USING FEDERAL
DOLLARS. IN READY TO WORK ON
IMPLEMENTATION- TO GET THE MONEY
TO OUR- ARE CONTINUING THEIR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WE ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING MORE DETAILS
ON OTHER PROPOSALS SUCH AS THE
50 DEGREES LIABILITY REQUIRE
FEDERAL RESEARCH INVESTMENT AND
THE PROPOSED SIX CHARGE AND
AGAIN- RIGHT TO WORK WITH
LEGISLATURE. YEAH OF THE- THANK
YOU. WELL I. EIGHTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHERUB MEMBERS THIS IS
RIGHT WITH AIR PRADA WE'RE THE
LARGEST PRETTY OF HIGH THE- I'M
CALLING TO SEE THE IN THE
GOVERNOR CHEN BUT FOR A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AT THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
SUPPORT GREEN HYDROGEN
DEVELOPMENT. PRODUCT ADVOCATES
FOR BILL OR POLICY LANGUAGE TO
BE TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AND THE
CARBON INTENSITY BE RECOGNIZED
AS THE TRUTH LAST MONTH OF
HYDROGEN. AS A RESULT WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
LANGUAGE BECOME TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL AND CARBON INTENSITY
BASED TO ALLOW ALL KINDS OF
GREEN HYDROGEN PROJECTS TO APPLY
AND AVOID PRESUPPOSING ANY
TECHNICAL TECHNOLOGY WINNERS FOR
STIFLING INNOVATION. WE ALSO
SUPPORT ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR
HYDROGEN THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
STATE TO BECOME MORE COMPETITIVE
IN THEIR BID. HYDROGEN HUB GRANT
AND STRUCTURING THEM IN A WAY
THAT SUPPORT ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION THE RAPID AND
WIDESPREAD DECARBONISATION OF
PORTS AND NEIGHBORING INDUSTRIAL
CLUSTERS AND OTHER END USERS.
FINALLY WE ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TEN
BILLION INVESTMENT IN ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS THE
TWO HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION FOR
INDUSTRIAL DECARBONISATION.
HOWEVER JUST AS WE ENCOURAGE
HYDROGEN FUNDING TO BE
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AND BASED ON
CARBON INTENSITY WE ENCOURAGE
YOU TO TAKE A SIMILAR APPROACH
ON INDUSTRIAL DECARBONISATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND HAVE A
GREAT DAY THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
LAUREN WASSER IN CALIFORNIA
POLICY MANAGER FOR THE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION I'M CALLING TO ACTIVE
SUPPORT FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCE
AND THIRTY BY THIRTY AND
SPECIFICALLY TO DRAW ATTENTION
TO PLANNING FOR COASTAL
RESILIENCE OF THIS COMMITTEE
KNOWS THE DOCKING ARE DEADLINE
TO DELIVER I ENORMOUS BACK. IN
PARTICULAR GOING TO NEED LOT
STAFF ADDRESS THE WORK CREATE. A
THIRD SEEDED WITH OTHER
RESTORATION IN NATURE BASED
LISTEN PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED AND THAT ARE DEDICATED
WITH THE STATE CRIME THE GOLD.
MARKING HERE TO ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF AND NGOS FOR
ENFORCEMENT FUNDS FOR THE CAUSE
THE COMMISSION TO BOTH BOLSTER
THOSE PROACTIVE EFFORTS. YES I
NEED A COUNTY A FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THE GATEKEEPER AND
GREETED VIOLATION BECAUSE LACK
IT'LL RESTORE PUBLIC ACCESS TO
TRAILHEADS LET'S GO. I CANYON
HAVE. BEEN LOOKING INTO LET'S.
ALL THAT MONEY WILL GO TO BACK
THE PUBLIC FOR THEIR CODE BLACK
AND REBELLION. AND THE
COMMISSION THE NEW PILE. BACKLOG
AND WE NEED THAT TO DRAW IT
THANK. BLINDSIDED FOR. HELLO HI
ECONOMY HOW OF THE GREEN
HYDROGEN COLA WE SUPPORT THE
HUNDRED MILLION PER GREEN
HYDROGEN AND THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET HOWEVER ECHOING
SOME OF THE OTHER COMMONERS- THE
GREEN PARTY COALITION REQUEST
BUT THE LANGUAGE BE REVIVED TO
BE TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL TO ALLOW
ALL TYPES OF GREEN HYDROGEN
PROJECTS TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
SPARK. LASTLY WE WOULD SUPPORT
ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR GREEN
HYDROGEN THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
STATE TO BE MORE COMPETITIVE.
BID FOR FEDERAL HYDROGEN HUB
GRANT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. THIRTY ONE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ONE IS NOW OPEN. JUST
POSTED. THANK YOU THIS IS ROBERT
MORGAN I'M CEO OF H. CYCLE WE
MAKE RENEWABLE HYDROGEN ORGANIC
WASTE WILL ECHO THE COMMENTS
THAT WE REALLY SUPPORT. THE
BUDGET FOR GREEN HYDROGEN BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE LANGUAGE
ALIGNED WITH OTHER PARTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA- RESOURCES CODE
ETCETERA TO BE TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL AND TO USE A CARBON
INTENSITY SCORE. OPUA DEFINITION
SO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND THANKS FOR YOUR
STAMINA GETTING FROM MORNING TO
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU. BLIND.
EIGHTY NINE. ONE EIGHTY NINE
RUNS NÓI PARDON I APOLOGIZE
PARDON ME. I RUN MY NAME'S KATIE
COMPTON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALTRAIN SAMTRANS WE WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIRMAN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THE COMMITTEE ALL
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND OF COURSE WERE
SPECIALLY GRATEFUL. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN IT'S GREAT
CHAMPIONS CALTRAIN
ELECTRIFICATION PROJECT FOR
MOVING FORWARD WITHOUT
ELECTRIFICATION PROJECT WILL
CONVERT OUR AGING DIESEL FLEET
TO HIGH PERFORMANCE ELECTRIC
TRAIN FLEET L. MAKE IT THE FIRST
ELECTRIFIED COMMUTER RAILROAD IN
CALIFORNIA AMONG THE MANY
BENEFITS OF THE PROJECT WILL
HELP FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE
RECOGNIZE THE COUNTY REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS- HOPING
THAT A ROBOT TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING. FROM THE STATE ANDTHIS
YEAR'S BUDGET WILL NOT ONLY HELP
ELECTRIFICATION PROJECT FOR
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE TO
MAKE SURE CALIFORNIANS HAVE A
WORLD CLASS AND SUSTAINABLE
PUBLIC TRANSIT SYSTEM A FUTURE
GENERATIONS WE SIGNED ON TO
RECENT LETTER THAT DESCRIBED THE
DETAILS THAT WERE SUPPORTING AND
WILL MAKE SURE THE COMMITTEE HAS
A COPY OF THAT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU. BLIND THIRTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK FOR YOUR TIME MY
NAME IS NORMAN ROGERS I'M WITH
USW LOCAL SIX SEVENTY SIX AND
I'M CALLING AS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FOR CLIMATE
JOBS COALITION. OR ASKING THAT
THE PILOT PROJECT FOR DISPLACED
POSSIBILE WORKERS WHICH ALREADY
HAS FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED CRESCENT PRINT EDITION
OF FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR DIRECT SUPPORT FOR FOSSIL
FUEL WORKERS THAT ABOVE SUFFERED
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A DROP IN
DEMAND FOR POSSIBLE PRODUCTS BUT
THIS WOULD BE DIRECT SUPPORT
PERPETRATING WAGE SUPPORTS ALSO
HEALTH CARE- WE KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S COMING BY
DESIGN THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
COMING WE'LL SEE THIS
CONTRACTION. BUT WE'VE ALSO
ALREADY SEEN IT HAPPEN IN
PARTICULAR AT THE MARATHON
MARTINEZ FACILITY WHERE ABOUT
7070% OF THE WORKFORCE- CLUSTER
JOBS DUE TO- THE FACILITY.
SWITCHING OVER TO RENEWABLE
DIESEL- IT'D TO THAT THERE'S
WILK. A PILOT PROJECT AND THIS
IS- AND ASK WITH NO DOLLAR
AMOUNT IT IS A WORDING CHANGE.
CURRENTLY THE LANGUAGE FOR THE
PILOT PROGRAM CALLS OUT- PARDON
ME. SKILLED AND TRAINED WE WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE AN ADJUSTMENT IN
ADDITION TO THAT THE SKILLED AND
TRAINED OR THOSE FOLKS COVERED
BY CBA TO MAKE IT AS INCLUSIVE
AS POSSIBLE FOR CALIFORNIA
WORKERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE NINETY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR BLOOM AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DAVID GRUBBS SPEAKING
FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL CENTER OF
SAN DIEGO. GIVEN THE
UNPRECEDENTED SURPLUS AND THE
URGENT NEED FOR CLIMATE ACTION
NOW IS THE TIME TO MAKE THE
NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS TO MINIMIZE AND
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CATASTROPHE. WE ARE URGING A
DOUBLING DOWN ON CLIMATE FUNDING
TO SEVENTY FIVE BILLION IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. WE SPECIFICALLY
HEARD SUPPORT FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS ON THE LAWCENTER
CORRIDOR CONNECTING THE TWO
LARGEST CITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS ROUTE IS THE SECOND MOST
USED IN THE NATION. PROVIDES AN
ALTERNATIVE TO DRIVING CARRY
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF FREIGHT
THAT IS A CRITICAL ELEMENT IN
THE NATIONAL DEFENSE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. YET IN
SOME PLCES IT CONSISTS OF A
SINGLE TRACK ON CENTURY OLD
WOODEN BRIDGES OR ON TROUBLING
COASTAL BLUFFS. ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS IN UPGRADING THIS
IMPORTANT RAIL LINK WILL
CONTINUE TO PAY DIVIDENDS FOR
HUNDREDS OF YEARS AND REDUCE
TRAVEL TIMES INCREASE BOTH
CHIPPED AND REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WHY. NINETY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIRMAN BLOOM AND
MEMBERS JIM WHITE'S ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID
TRANSIT DISTRICT BUT DISTRICTS
BAY AREA LARGEST TRANSIT
OPERATORS HAVE IDENTIFIED
CAPITAL FUNDING SHORTFALLS OF
TEN BILLION OVER FOUR YEARS
SEVENTEEN BILLION OVER TEN
YEARS- WE WOULD WELCOME
ALIGNMENT WITH THE SENATE'S
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE OF TWENTY
BILLION- INCLUDING ELEVEN POINT
EIGHT BILLION DEDICATED TO
TRANSIT PROJECTS. TWO POINT NINE
BILLION FOR CLIMATE RESISTANCE
AND ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS WHICH ALIGN WITH PARTS
GOALS TO IMPROVE STATION ACCESS
AND PROTECT THE OVERALL SYSTEM
FROM CLIMATE CHANGE HAZARDS
LASTLY WE WOULD URGE- FOR THE
TERCET PROGRAM TO ADD SOME
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY- WITHIN
THE RULES OF THE PROGRAM AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
STAFF ON THE COMMITTEE ON WHAT
THAT MIGHT LOOK LIKE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
. WHY ONE HUNDRED. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS NATALIE CALLING ON
BEHALF LEADERSHIP COUNCIL A
CONSISTENT WITH THE SENATE
PROPOSAL WE MUST FIND UNIVERSAL
INCOME RATE ASSISTANCE FOR WATER
AND WASTEWATER SERVICES AND
ENSURE THAT ALL WATER
PORTABILITY PROGRAMS ARE
ACCESSIBLE TO UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS FUNDING FOR EXAMPLE
MEDITATION MUST INCLUDE A 30%
SET ASIDE FOR PROJECTS THAT
BENEFIT DRINKING WATER
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
SUPPORT COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. WE
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL TO
APPROPRIATE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
PER WATER GAP HOWEVER WE NEED TO
ENSURE THE FUNDING IS AVAILABLE
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS
OF LEGAL STATUS ON SUPPORT FOR
THE EASY FUNDING PROGRAMS LIKE
THESE BEFORE EIGHT OUR MUCH
NEEDED TO MAKE THE EVENT A
COUPLE SMALL INCOME HOUSEHOLD
FOR HARM DOUBLE BY HIGH GAS
PRICES THE PROGRAM INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OF CELEBRATION-
ARE ALL CRITICAL TO ENSURING
THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS THE
VEHICLE AND THE BILL EQUITABLY.
ADDITIONALLY WE STRONGLY URGE
COLLABORATION WITH COMMUNITY
GROUPS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIBLE
PROGRAMS TO MEET CLIMATE GOALS
AND IT IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE
THAT ALL THE FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING PRIOR
CONCEALING STATIONS AMONG
FREIGHT CORRIDORS AND INTACT WE
SUPPORT ONE POINT TWO BILLION IN
FUNDING FOR RELIGIOUS PROVIDING
CRUCIAL THAT RELIEF TO
HOUSEHOLDS THAT WERE UNABLE TO
PAY UTILITY BILLS DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND LASTLY STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE HUNDRED SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR RESILIENCE
UNDER WHICH ARE A CRITICAL PIECE
OF PHYSICAL AND SOCIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ARE
INSTRUMENTAL IN BUILDING
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE. BOTH
DURING THE Q. EXTREME CLIMATE
EVENTS AND IN THE LONG TERM
WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE FUNDING IN
THE BUDGET AND WHILE WE ARE
ADVOCATING FOR A TOTAL OF ONE
BILLION TO WEEKS A WHITE CAL OF
NEED FOR C. R. C. THE ONE
HUNDRED SEVEN MILLION ALLOCATION
IS. A CRUCIAL START THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BLIND WHY OH TWO-
THANKS SO MUCH. SIDES OF LITTLE
BACKGROUND NOISE THERE- MY NAME
IS SERRA AND ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE WHERE CALIFORNIA ARE
PASSED REFORM A COALITION MADE
UP OF MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE STATE
WHAT KIND OF SPORT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THREE CRITICAL ITEMS
FIRST FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
DEVELOP AND EXPAND REGIONAL
FARMER TRAINING CENTERS THAT
PROVIDE CULTURALLY RELEVANT
ASSISTANCE FOR SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS BEGINNING
FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS IN
ORGANIC AND SUSTAINABLE
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES. THAT
PROVIDE MULTIPLE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR PILOT
LOGICAL CONTROL AND FACTORIES
INFRASTRUCTURE TO CONSTRUCT AND
FACTORIES THAT PRODUCE
BENEFICIAL ORGANISMS AND THE
PART OF ECOLOGICAL INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT CALIFORNIA'S
UNDERFUNDED BIOLOGICAL CONTROL
IS A CRITICAL METHOD TO CONTROL
PASS AND FARMERS NEED SUPPORT
AND ADDITIONAL PEST MANAGEMENT
SO THAT THEY CAN USE THAT
PASSED. ARE PROJECTED TO
INCREASE AT THE SAME TIME THAT
PESTICIDES ARE PROJECTED TO
BECOME LESS EFFECTIVE AS THERE'S
NOT OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
FINALLY TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION TO HER
APARTMENT BY THERE'S COMMUNITY
EDUCATORS AN EXTENSION
SPECIALIST THE SPECIALIST AND
CERTIFIED ORGANIC AGRICULTURE.
SMALL FARM ADVISING AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AND MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT- ALTHOUGH THESE ITEMS
WERE ALLOCATED FUNDING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S VERY BUDGET OR THE ME
REVISED TODAY CALIFORNIA HAS
VASTLY UNDER INVESTED IN
AGRICULTURE THAT BEST PROTECTS
THE CLIMATE WATER SOIL AND AIR
QUALITY AND COMMUNITY HEALTH AND
WE URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER THIS REALLY MODEST
TOTAL ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION OF.
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU. LINE. TWENTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING- MY
NAME IS NAOMI MARTINEZ I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA BARNATHAN
DUSTIN AND- I. AND THE COMMENTS
THE- THERE ARE DISMAYED- BUT I'M
ALSO- WANTED TO PUT AN END ON
RECORD- MY DISAPPOINTMENT FOR
THE BOTH OF WHAT JUST HAPPENED-
REJECTING THE CALIFORNIA RIVER
AREA SOURCES MORE PROPOSALS
ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY CENTER DEDICATION A HARD
WORKED FOR TWENTY YEARS TO
PROMOTE EACH DAY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. THIS ASSIST CONCERNING
BUT AGENTS LIKE CARPET GOING TO
THE RIGHT THING OR NOT GIVING
THEM THAT MONEY IN THE FUNDS
THAT THEY NEED TO DO IT- CUTTING
THAT EACH DAY ELEMENT IN OR IN
PRINCIPLE IN A DOCUMENT THE
THIRD SHOW ANYTHING FOR OUR
COMMUNITY UNLESS YOU HAVE A AN
ACTUAL PLAN AND COMMITTED STAFF
TO WORK WITH US AND THAT THE
BOAT THAT WAS TAKEN TODAY THAT-
ABSENT THAT THE FABRIC AND THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION NOT TO
INCLUDE. THE FUNDING THAT CAR
WAS REQUESTING FOR DEATH IT'S A
POLICY OF SANDY DAY MEMBER- WE
WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH
CARBON AN ELDER AGENCIES WILLING
TO PRIORITIZE EATING I WOULD
LOOK FORWARD TO RECEIVING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IN THE
THEATER TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN AND
I JUST WANT TO END BY SAYING
THAT- IF YOU WERE TO CARE ABOUT
MY RUN CONDUCTED COMMUNITIES
FIND OUT RESOURCES TO SUPPORT US
AND STOP NONE DON'T ASK THEM TO
STOP RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE
BASED ON JUST STRIKING A NUMBER-
IN AND IN THE BUDGET. BUT DON'T
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION THE
IMPACT THEIR HOBBY. IN THE
DAYLIGHT THANK YOU. THANK VERY
MUCH. LINE ONE OH SEX. BUT AFTER
SHARE BUT COMMITTEE I NEED THE
CREDIT WITH SILICON LEADERS
GROUP AND WE WERE HOPE TO SEE IF
BY FOR IN THE LEVEL ROSE BY
THREE BILLION IN THE GUY MAYBE
BY YEAH WHAT YOU PROPOSE IN JAN
. HE WILL PROVIDE DIRECT JEFF
BILLIONS OF HAVE BEEN FOR
STRUCTURE AND ECONOMIC GAP THAT
INPUTS OF THE BAY AREA IN WAY IF
THE MEDIA ACTION IS NOT TAKEN TO
PROTECT OUR- WITH A FORCE THE
SENATE BUDGET BECAUSE ANNOUNCED
BY SENATE PRO TEM ATKINS AND
BUDGET SURE SKINNER BECAUSE OF
THE TEAM STAND INVESTMENTS
CRITICAL CRIED PRIORITY AT
NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR DOUBLING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TO YOUR
INVESTMENT MYSTICAL CONSERVING
DEEPER CUTS OREGONIANS. FROM
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION TO ONE
BILLION DOLLARS THE COURT
CONSERVANCY IS ALREADY
IDENTIFIED FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN NECESSARY
FLOOD PROTECTION AND RESTORATION
PROJECT IN THE BAY AREA ALONE
SIGN DIFFICULT THAT'S METALLIC
THAT WE ONLY HAVE UNTIL TWENTY
THIRTY TO GET THE POTENTIAL
PROJECT TEMPLATES SUPPORT WATERS
RIGHT TO PASSED AND WE HAVE DONE
OUR PART LOCALLY WITH A PARK
PARCEL TAX ASSESSMENT. FINALLY
WE HAVE SUBMITTED THE BUDGET
LETTER TO FIND BY THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL THE BAY AND BALLY WATER
TO CHAIR BLOOM AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ALONG WITH SUPPORT
FROM LOCAL ELECTED LEADERS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. I
AM L. A. HI YOU FOR TIME MY NAME
IS MY APPROACH AND I MAKE POLY
LOW FORESTRY TODAY I ALSO WORKED
IN THE WHITE RACE TO BIOFUELS
INDUSTRY IF SOMEBODY CLEAN I
ALSO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL OF A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR GREEN HYDROGEN BUT
REQUEST THAT THE FUNDING
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE CARBON
NEGATIVE HYDROGEN FROM BIOMASS.
AS THE FUNDING IS CURRENTLY
LIMITED TO ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN
EXPANSION ABOUT SUPPORT
DIVERSIFIED PRODUCTION OF CARBON
NEGATIVE HYDROGEN AND SUPPORT
WILDFIRE BILLS REDUCTIONS AND
POST FIRE REHABILITATION THREE
USING THE STORAGE WHAT WAYS TO
PRODUCE GREEN FIELD THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. H.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IS THE
FINAL CALL FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE DO NOT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO SECOND TIME
BUT THAT WILL MOVE YOU FROM THE
KILL. LINE A DETAILED. HELLO MY
LIMITS CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
CANADIAN FROM ABOUT THAT LITTLE
BIT OF THE GREENING INSTITUTE
OUT OF CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
THAT PACKAGE IN PARTICULAR- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ACCELERATE ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS TO INVEST IN
PROGRAMS LIKE THE PINK CARDS
BRAUCHEN GIVE LIST AT THIS
PROGRAM THE MOBILITY PROGRAMS
AND- IT NEEDED CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE- IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN. CARTS FOR ALL I JUST
WANTED TO KNOW THAT FOR THE
REMAINING IS TO- WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE BOTH FUNDS SHIFTED AROUND
RIGHT NOW IT HAS TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION GOING TO STATE
WIDE PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR TO
IMPLEMENTED- DISTRICTS WHICH WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT REVERSED
AND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
ACTUALLY BE DIRECTED TO THE
EXISTING IMPLEMENTING OUR
DISTRICTS AND FIFTY MILLION GOAL
TO THE STATEWIDE EXPANSION- WE
ARE SUPPORTED A STATEWIDE
EXPANSION HOWEVER STATEWIDE
ADMINISTRATION IS- EIGHT BE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN THERE YET
TO SUPPORT THE STATEWIDE-
IMPLEMENTATION. SO WE RATHER
FOCUS ON THE EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND PROGRAMS THAT ARE COMMITTED
TO THE NET OUTCOME BEEN TARGETED
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND SO FOR NOW WE WILL HOLD
FIFTY- THAT THE FUNDS ARE THEN
DIRECTED- THAT MAJORITY OF THE
PARTY DIRECTED TO THE EXISTING
OUR DISTRICT AND STATEWIDE ONLY
RECEIVE A FIFTY BILLION
ADDITIONALLY YOU WANT TO
SUPPORT- THE HEART OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION COMMITTED
TO- TRANSIT AGENCIES TO HELP
SUPPORT OUR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS- IN THESE TIMES. AS
WELL AS THE FUNDING THAT HAS
BEEN- SUGGESTED FOR THE ACTIVE.
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM THANK YOU
FOR TAX. THE YOU. ONE ONE PATENT
. GET AFTERNOON CARE MA'AM- ROD
BREWER FOR SOME CAL ADDED- MARK
INTO TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
MAY REVISE BEFORE FOR THE CAT
PRO. FOR EARLY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
WITH YOU AND YOUR IN YOUR
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU LINE ONE OH FOUR.
HELLO. HI MY NAME BROUGH BURKE
I'M CALLING FROM THE LOS ANGELES
NEIGHBORHOOD LAND TRUST AND WE
SUPPORT AND APPRECIATE THE
MINISTRATIONS MAY REVISION
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR ITS
INVESTMENT IN INTO THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE STATE PARKS
CONSERVATION DEPARTMENT AND
CONVERT. CONSERVATION EFFORT
THERE THE THIRTY BY THIRTY
CLIMATE RESILIENCE WE OFTEN
SUPPORT THE MINISTRATIONS ONE
HUNDRED MILLION TO THE COURT
TRAVEL PARTNERSHIP HOWEVER WE
URGE THE FINAL BUDGET INCLUDES
SIGNIFICANT. ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT THE SENATE HAS PROPOSED IN
ITS COMMENT BUDGET INCLUDING AND
DISTRAUGHT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THAT THIRTY BY THIRTY AND
THIRTY BILLION FOR COASTAL
RESILIENCE SENATE PROPOSAL
BETTER REFLECTS. THE SCALE OF
WHAT IS NEEDED TO ACHIEVE
CALIFORNIA THIRTY BY THIRTEEN
CLIMATE RESILIENT CULT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE L. TWO L.
TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU
OPERATOR AND- THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO GAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
TODAY. AND OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS IT'S BEEN AN HONOR
EVERYONE WE'RE ADJOURNED. YOU
MISTER CHAIR.